inside the story and you're like oh wait
a minute
and um I'm not going to say I was
thoroughly convinced by the
representatives of the nhspca but I
think they did make some interesting
points um some points that really made
me uh it gave me pause about some things
I think
that there there's a concern that I have
and I think many other people have that
um that there's
people being violated at the hands of
the state and and but at the same time
they're probably I'm assuming are a lot
of instances where there are animal
animal abuse or neglect cases where the
system is working excellently it's
saving animals not necessarily from
people that are intending to do harm but
just they've just lost their ability to
know what to do or take care of them and
so I I think one of my fears is I don't
want to throw the baby out with the
bathat um I don't I think I think
there's a a fine line that we're going
to have to walk with each one of the
little Parts because there's several
major parts in this bill and each one I
think may require some some thorough um
thinking through um and um I I I'm
looking forward to the discussion
because I I'm I hope that people aren't
um seeing this so black and white I
think that there's there's a lot of Gray
in here and I'm hoping that we can do
something to protect people from ever
being violated in the way that was
discussed with the Lee case and I'm not
familiar with the Lee case myself so I
don't know what what's true and what's
not but assuming that what was said was
true I mean that's pretty horrible and I
think we should do what we can to stop
that but I also don't want to throw the
baby out with the bath water I I tend to
agree with you uh representative King
however you know had I been able to ask
questions of um the folks that testified
I would have been very interested to
know for all the reports where the ASPCA
comes out to investigate how many of
them have they walked away from and said
no there's not a problem here um I just
tend to think that there is
um perhaps an overzealousness on their
part um I only because I feel like in a
sense they have an
interest not only in
Humane areas but they have an interest
financially in um
in taking animals away from people and
there's a conflict there that I see and
I think that that's something that
really needs to be teased out and
discussed and and for us to fix because
um it's a problem and this is something
that is not um just being seen in New
Hampshire uh when I went to the state
agricultural uh uh and Rural leadership
conference this uh past couple of months
ago these this kind of thing is
happening all over the country from
these animal activists or Animal Humane
Societies whatever they they have been
harassing Farmers they have been
targeting farmers and um you know they
they have a certain set of beliefs where
they don't feel animals should be
working they don't feel that um Farmers
should own animals or or or um you know
produce milk or produce meat or whatever
and they will do whatever is necessary
to shut them down so I I you
know that's okay they can have their
opinion and they can have their way of
doing things but I I don't think that
that
zealousness um should be allowed to
disrupt and and put strike fear in the
in the heart of the people who are
producing food for us um so we have to
we have to figure it out represent Bixby
yeah I um to some degree I share your
concern in terms of the uh the Humane
organizations and the steps they take I
think that what has what we saw in Lee
was clearly not done correctly right
however I am also hesitant to paint them
with a broad brush with having a um you
fundamentally anti-
agriculture um bias I I think that I I'm
you that may be out there in some cases
I but I don't want to paint with paint
with a broad brush and I I don't see
that as being a primary motivator in New
Hampshire uh which it doesn't mean that
it isn't there at some level somewhere
but uh I don't think that I don't think
that what we're hearing from you know
other larger um agricultural states that
have a different Dynamic is necessarily
entirely applicable to what we're doing
and uh and I so I don't think that
should be you know the way that I don't
think that it makes sense for that to
guide what we do here right now uh I
think that um
but um one of the things that uh well I
don't know how there there are a number
of details that that need to be
addressed okay uh one thing that
occurred to me that I don't I don't see
in the bill is uh the um is a
clear a method of U letting the anim the
animal known owner know all of their
rights so uh we do have the
uh have uh one line in there about uh
the person charged he'll be aware of the
PTI the ability to make the petition but
um what I'm concerned about in the Lee
case is
that uh the owner was led to give up
ownership of her animals in in a way
that she was not aware that she was
doing that absolutely and and there
needs to be uh clear there needs to be
something very
clear so that the owner of the animal is
fully aware that if they say yes in this
instance they are giving up ownership
yep uh and so that's something I think
we we need to add
um so uh okay absolutely I I'm
absolutely in agreement representative
Kenny thank you um the one thing that I
didn't uh think of or ask yesterday was
um why in a couple of months did they
offer Donna to buy her goats back for
$40,000 what changed at her facility her
farm that would have allowed that and
they also wanted to sell her back one of
her goats at 400 $0000 that she just
purchased so I really wondered what
where did that figure come from
$40,000 in what changed that they could
have allowed those goats back to the
farm that's a good point representative
H Haskins thank you madam chair it won't
surprise anyone that my sympathies are
entirely with Miss Woods I think she was
treated abominably
and I was shrined that the SPCA
organization which I have supported in
the past um felt that nothing was done
wrong they wouldn't do anything
differently and that I was appalled by
that um I had heard about this case I
did not know the details talk about
impugning motives I think that was all
over this case and almost implied that
you know people owners can be mentally
ill
and a colleague and I talked about the
fact that she happens to be a senior
citizen and I think she was prayed upon
I think there was no way she was uh
supported enabled with the kind of
information that would be necessary to
stand up to what was happening and I
also think there's almost a dichotomy
between law enforcement and Humane
treatment law enforcement is trained in
a certain way for a certain job and when
it comes down to it we we rely on that I
don't think that it was used properly in
this case and and what representative
Kenny said is so bothersome
so obviously the bill is going to be
amended in ways but I don't think the
other side clothed themselves in glory
yesterday thank you representative
Barber yes I had a question to um can
you explain to me um if there is in fact
that Financial tie between the state and
the NH um SPCA I mean what do they have
to gain why are they our primary go-to
for this type of case I'm unfamiliar
represent big thank you yeah so um I
don't know the full history of it uh uh
commissioner Jasper might know a little
bit more but uh the
um one of the issues in terms of uh
animal investigations is that they're
complicated and expensive and uh the I
think the idea of having uh the Humane
Societies essentially
deputized uh came up whenever whenever
that ended up in law I suspect that it
was a way of saving State money by uh
having some private organization that it
could be delegated to but uh from what I
see in statute there is no
oversight uh and so there's not there's
not a direct payment to the Humane
Societies uh but there is a um but there
is a umire for desire for them to to to
take on some of the work that the
state's not willing to pay for I I see
uh U commissioner raising his hand would
thoughts thank you there is absolutely
no relationship between the state in any
Humane organ Humane Society we regulate
them we
inspect what has happened in
particularly in in this case I mean
there was that confusing language left
when last the statute was amended and I
don't know when it was that left the
officer of Humane organization or
whatever it is in there which hopefully
will be taken out and that was only for
protective custody made no sense to have
left it there but we all know how things
work with with legislation but we never
recommend to any um any police Police
Department any specific organization to
take custody in this particular case
this was totally instigated by the
humane society and then they directly
worked with the police and the state had
as a matter of fact my inspectors were
so uncomfortable with what was going on
they called the state veterinarian said
nobody's asking us for advice we didn't
have the right to inject our opinions
and so they said we're so uncomfortable
can we leave yeah and they were given
the permission to leave um you
know so there is a you know there is
some tension frankly between the
Department of Agriculture and the new
Humane Society of New Hampshire um and
so that's not a place that we have
actually in my tenure have um
recommended that anybody come in we do
give um
a number of names when horses are seized
when livestock is seized you might want
to call ABCD to see if they have space
and but we'd never make the calls on
their behalfs we might call someplace
and say do you have space available for
this type of animal and then we would
say to the police you know again here's
the list and we happen to know um that
this organization or you know sometimes
it could even be for horse it could be
uh the University of New Hampshire it's
a call to see if they have spaces in
their Stables if the animals don't have
disease so you know we do try to work to
help the police because we do understand
that they don't know necessarily who to
turn to but we do not have a
relationship with any
organization anybody have any questions
uh representative Howard and then
Scully thank you madam chair this is it
actually directly for the commissioner
so I can wait if if people have
questions directly for him yeah you may
ask okay um so I'm this whole thing I'm
very very confused by the whole story
and the whole bill I think that there it
appears to me that there are a bunch of
steps missing you know like like
identifying expertise in in a particular
kind of animal it sounds like some of
the decisions about these goats were
made by people who don't know enough
about goats um and and the step between
the person who observed who for who was
not an official in any way just was on
the farm observed what she thought was a
problem goes directly instead of talking
you know trying to learn more about it
or something goes directly to the
authorities and and then the authorities
seem to take a large leap too so so I
think that if there's any way in the
legislation to to insert steps that that
clarify it because to me the whole thing
was just I couldn't understand I
couldn't understand it from beginning to
end from the story of the of the farm to
the uh steps taken by the
SPCA thank you representative
Scully thank you and good morning
um an amazing and sad tale that we heard
and I think we really should do
something about this uh I was going back
to the uh testimony given by the SPCA uh
specifically the uh Humane agent and I'm
very uncomfortable with the idea that
that without a third party training and
certification program that that person
is any more qualified to make a decision
regarding an animal than than a police
officer who shows up so if absent that I
think they should be struck from the
ability to start taking animals uh I'm
also the issue of
them it being owner for somebody to
provide written notification of a
person's rights I I also reject that
argument I mean the police drive around
with their ticket books they also
usually have their binders and folders
you can slide one of those in there and
it can be available when uh the
situation calls for it especially if
it's going to be a planned visit that
could be uh done by the police I don't
think that's honorous I do have one
other concern and that is that we are
dealing with living things and if they
are confiscated for a later trial for
animal cruelty or something um I think
it's very important to establish the
Baseline line of the condition of the
animals at the moment of confiscation
because if they're held for two weeks
and they don't receive the correct
treatment especially if they're already
have an illness to being treated for if
you look at the animal two weeks later
they'll look a lot worse than it did
when it was taken so I think I I just
think we have to make sure that when
they are especially if they're going to
uh pursue a criminal action that we're
very clear that the uh conditions of the
animals have to be established right up
front um for any subsequent trial and if
I I have one other thought if I may I'm
wondering if this is also um an
opportunity to start to use the
improvements in technology and um allow
some type of uh teleconferencing with a
Veterinary a qualified Veterinary I mean
you know people have their their cameras
now and if you if the person can't be
there in person because of uh staff
limitations even to have them on the
line and with the with the camera so
that the vet can ask the right question
show me this part of the animal um it
might be a good to put that option into
this bill to increase the chances that
we'll have a qualified person making
that decision when the decision needs to
be
made represent Bixby yeah I um I I agree
with a lot of what you say I'm not sure
about the T the telea health uh aspect
of it because uh it's um one of the
there are some aspects of uh being able
to assess the entire context that could
really get missed and uh someone who's
holding that camera could be holding it
very
selectively uh so um I I would hesitate
to say that um the uh that um just doing
it by by a you know by a remote vision
would be sufficient to really assess the
situ situation however I entirely agree
that uh the there needs to be a third-
party person who is not associated with
either the um the accused or with the uh
investigating um or or with a
complainant that can assess what the
context is and what the uh and what the
condition of the animals are is I I have
a question actually for our commissioner
world do you think it would be
beneficial to have a I don't know a
special office within the state
veterinarians
Department uh who could sort of be a a
task force or be on call or uh be
available to answer questions either by
phone or if they could be called out to
a a report um in a perfect world if
there was enough money to go around if
there was whatever do you think it would
be beneficial to have that kind of
resource within the Department of
Agriculture I'm not sure that that would
be even in a perfect world if that would
be coste effective because of the the
few cases that we have although there
you know maybe one one a month um I
think you know Ely what we need is more
more Staffing in the department to do
the overall mission what I will you know
will say is that you know there's this
case and there's a couple where I don't
believe the law was really followed the
way it should have been because you got
to step step back and I know that
protective custody is what again what
people think was being used here I think
there are fixes here that take care of
that so that will largely go away if you
look at the conf
a there needs to be that assessment and
the assessments are done um largely from
the property line or from statements of
people who are allowed on the property
because remember we can't go trespass we
can't just go in and say we want to look
at your animals and that was part of the
problem that went on in the Lee
situation as they came in as we want to
help you we want to you know Assist you
um and that really wasn't what went on
but in most cases you're going to have
the the court order and so now the
police department when are handling it
correctly are going to reach out to us
and we are going to coordinate with them
when we go to issue the uh
actual um yeah the actual court order so
we're going to be with the police uh
staff from my office is going to be
there doing an evaluation of the animals
on site at that time and then if the
police follow our recommendations things
tend to go
well sometimes the problem is and this
is part of the the issue of not having a
cost of care in in the past where we
wanted all of the horses in a situation
seized they were afraid of the cost
being the town so for weeks and weeks we
kept going back we kept watching the
animals they didn't see deterior
until I finally told that Police
Department I was not sending any people
there anymore because what you were
doing to my people was cruel and unusual
punishment essentially because they were
watching animals just get worse and
worse um but when they follow our
recommendations and say yes these are
the animals that we believe should be
seized things go go well and things um
are not terrible there's these couple of
outliers
um and and I think the bill addresses um
most of those if not all of them um I
have some suggestions to to make the
bill better that I gave to your your
chairman um but you know there is
definitely a problem here but it's
generally when the agencies do not
consult with the Department prior and
again you know we get back to Staffing
level and not every case requires
requires that but there aren't that many
seizures of large animals representative
Bixby yeah I'm just looking at the clock
and we have a hearing coming up at 10:
uh and uh I this is extremely
complicated we're not going to get it
solved this morning uh even if we you
know just blew through to worked till
noon uh so I think this might need to go
to the
subcommittee uh and uh have some have a
chance for some more thorough work okay
I think that's a um a a good um
suggestion um let's see who is on
subcommittee all right hold
on um let's see the animal protection
and Licensing committee subcommittee
okay so uh representative Kat chairs
that we have representative Kenny
Freeman H Haskins and
suus so um I will consult with them uh
with at least representative kto if I
can get a hold of her I know she's had a
death in the family but um we'll see
what we can do and if she's not
available we'll we'll have someone else
who can share that and as a um as a
reminder uh everyone on the committee is
welcome to go to the subcommittee
hearing and participate fully except for
it except for voting so um right so I I
think that this is not trying to exclude
anybody this is just trying to move it
to a more efficient venue yes um I I
would like to try and maybe arrange
something that we can do either Friday
this Friday or Monday because time is of
the essence now we're kind of getting
you know bearing down on uh on our March
20th uh date of getting all our bills
out and um yeah bill is going to need a
little bit of work and uh it also takes
time to draft it through o El
representative King uh question so I
think based on what I've heard so far it
seems like there's a lot of support
within the committee for this bill but
there's also a lot of work that needs to
be done if the subcommittee is not
really able
to uh fix it all before our end date um
would it be amendable to um the chair
to retain the bill and then work on it
over the summer and then come back with
something that really is solid or do you
feel that it needs to be done now I I
think it needs to be done now yeah I
don't want to wait another year and um I
think that you know we have enough
information right now to make uh
substantial changes to the bill well you
know the changes that we have discussed
and points that were brought up during
testimony and so forth um some of the
more minor
points will have to be discussed in the
in the subcommittee but I'm going to uh
in the next couple of days work on the
changes that are we know that we want to
make and some of the other things will
just have to be discussed in the
subcommittee representative Bixby yeah
so uh another possibility might be I
there are clearly some things that need
to happen right away uh there are other
things that could perhaps be um done at
you know uh on a long longer time scale
uh it might be possible to add a section
to the bill that creates a study
committee to study the entire chapter
and make further recommendations about
it rather than uh than just these
isolated points that's a very good point
thank you okay with that I'm going
to
yeah get my magic gabble out um for the
next for the hearing um so with that I'm
going to end our work session for this
particular
Bill and um there will be more to come
so thank you all for for joining us
today and uh letting us your comments
and uh we will proceed with working on
this bill and um go along with the uh
upcoming hearing so I'm going to end the
work session now and I will open up the
hb250 enabling local governing bodies to
regulate the musling of dogs um I
noticed before we begin um I noticed
that we do have a furry friend in the
back here and I would like to know
whether that uh friend of yours is a
service animal or
not okay thank you because um we don't
allow animals in our committee rooms and
unless there are they are certified
service
animals thank you thank you for that I
appreciate
it
[Music]
um
sp250
uh why do I not have that bill
nobody had it um I had to pick one up oh
I'm sorry yeah I do need a copy of the
Bill thank
much do all the committee members have a
copy of the bill it wasn't it wasn't in
our green packet so yeah people people
need to get let get everybody situated
okay I am going to open up the hearing
for hb250 enabling local governing
bodies to regulate the musling of dogs
and with us this morning is
representative Newell please come to sit
and welcome to environment and
agriculture
good morning thank you madam chair and
thanks to the committee uh for giving me
your time and attention today my name is
jod n and I rep I represent the good
folks of cheser 4 over there in Keen
this particular piece of legislation um
is a simple and straightforward tweak
enabling local governing bodies to
regulate musling requirements for dogs
licensed in that municipality as you
know we are a Dylan's rule state and so
of course Authority must be expressly
granted to localities in order for them
to do this a few months back our city
council um in Keen attempted to do the
right thing in responding to a serious
concern from a constituent after a
tragic encounter with a known aggressive
dog in order to provide for the safety
of the broader community of people and
also our fur babies um the Keen city
leaders proposed that demonstrably
aggressive dogs be required to wear a
protective muzzle when in public I want
to also take this opportunity uh to
remind everyone that this is not only in
the interest of the broader public but
also the aggressive animal and their
owners as well um as allowing this dog
to be put in situations for whatever
reason um that for whatever reason have
proven to elicit dangerous and seemingly
uncontrollable behavior is likely is
like playing Russian roulette the most
Humane solution in this situation is a
preventative one unfortunately in site
of in spite of their good intentions
according to the law this was not under
the council's uh purview so it's up to
us to pass legislation that will allow
the city to implement a reasonable and
effective solution my bill today very
simply allows them to do the right thing
for their constituents and with that um
if it's okay with you I need to SK
skattle to get to executive committee in
my own session but I would really like
to pass it off next um to Deb to share
the story that inspired what we are
informally in affectionately calling
suzette's
law okay thank you who who did you say
you wanted to Deb right here uh she did
Deb
Deborah oh I have no pin card for you oh
I'm sorry she's I'm sorry I thought she
I thought she'd pass it in my bad I did
not the big chairs yes
okay good morning my name's debor
leblank I need you to be closer to the
mic please okay sorry good morning my
name's Deb La blank
um two years ago uh I was out walking uh
in my neighborhood and uh 8:00 in the
morning and all of a sudden a dog
charged at us grabbed my dog leg dragged
her across the road um threw her in the
air was a horrific scene we stopped
traffic um she almost lost her leg I had
to rush her in for emergency surgery I
got bit um trying to get the dog off of
my dog it took three people to pry the
dog's jaw off of her leg
um come to find out uh the police
department told me uh which I did report
immediately of course um that uh the dog
that attacked my dog had an aggressive
history and had a couple of months
before um had mauled another dog uh
during a downtown uh Pride Fest
event um if the uh Community had
been aware or allowed to order the owner
to muzzle that dog my dog or any other
dog would not have been attacked um and
it was a preventable solution so so I
would request you strongly consider the
fact that when dogs have a vicious dog
or pardon me when people have a vicious
dog or a dog with a bite history that
when they bring that dog into public
wear a preventative
muzzle thank you okay questions from the
committee oh representative King thank
you madam chair thank you for your
testimony today um I think I would have
asked this question of the sponsor but
unfortunately I couldn't um but in your
case was the dog um like brought out by
the owner or did it escape a fenc yard
or was it always allowed to ro free I'm
just curious what the what the situation
was with that dog being out on the loose
at that time sure the dog was not loose
uh we were walking on a sidewalk and the
owner uh did have a leash on the dog he
had his head turned and was bagging uh
feces and I think think his attention
was not on the dog and the dog broke
away okay and we were on a public road
welcome um represent
Howard um I had a similar experience
with with a dog that I was watching and
um the the dog that attacked it was his
second attack and um he was deemed a
vicious dog and would have been put down
on the third
you know the police told us that he'd be
put down on his third offense so he's
now tied up he's he's a good dog but um
it seems like musling is a is a superior
um alternative to life-threatening
punishment would you agree agreed it's a
alternative okay any other questions
from the
committee and did uh I have a question
did you I know you said you called this
in as a report to the
police did you speak to anyone else um
from the state or the Department of
Agriculture or
anybody I did speak before uh the city
council in Kean in Keen yes so were were
the Selectmen or the I don't know what
they're in Keen what they are did do
they have like an animal control officer
that knew about this
dog there was no Animal control officer
in Keen at the time which did compound
the
problem do you feel that uh if they had
had an animal control
officer uh that maybe something would
have done been done about the dog the
dog owner or the
dog um I was informed by the officer
that was working uh with me on the case
that the uh owner was uh contacted and
the dog was
quarantined um subsequently um I don't
walk in that area of the neighborhood
anymore I'm now fearful um and the dog
has been aggressive to other dogs but
this owner continues to take that dog
out on public
sidewalks okay but because there's no
Authority for the police to say you need
to muzzle the dog if you take it out
so but the dog is is on a leash and is
under the control of the person well it
was on a leash and under the control of
that person at the time of the incident
okay um I I believe that there there are
some statutes having to do with um
vicious dogs or whatever represent Bixby
yes to find that uh just if we look at
the bill uh the existing language is
that the local governing body may make
such additional laws and regulations
concerning the licensing and restraining
of dogs as it deems reasonable and
uh apparently the city's
Council uh made the um assessment that
musling was not uh covered by
that because uh that musling would not
be strictly would would not fit into the
the definition of of
restraining um that's you know I I can't
speak to what the what the you know that
decision by the city's Council but um I
think that uh it probably I if if that
is a gray area I don't see a problem in
in fixing
it okay well um thank you I appreciate
any other questions from the
committee represent Penza you look like
you have a question bubbling to the top
there uh thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
this um this incident was that involved
your pet correct okay um the one I have
here now
um you might have already um you might
have already answered this or or talked
about this in your
testimony um I just read the what the
city of Keane came forward and are does
the city of Kean at this point feel as
if this um that we need this kind of
like enabling legislation um to be able
to um because they don't they don't have
the authority to be able to do this on
their own in regards with um following
the state rules okay
yes
um can I ask what happened after the
incident took place like his there
been you know is there is there anybody
liable for you know the injuries to your
that well I like I've stated there was
no Animal control officer at the time in
Keen so it was a very
um I got bit in my hand and there was no
Animal control officer so the police
department didn't know what to do with
me I got wrong information I got rabies
treatments when I didn't need to get
rabies treatments
um it was a difficult time and this uh
owner of the other dog is not a
responsible owner and well known to the
police department
as being a aggressive person and I
didn't want to pursue it I was
fearful um I didn't want to go out in
public um it
and now when I go out in public on the
sidewalks I'm always looking for other
dogs and I'm wondering are they vicious
are they going to bite us um and I never
thought of that before the incident um I
love dogs I've always had dogs um and
now I think a a responsible owner if
their dog has a bite history really
should put a muzzle on their dogs if
they continue to take them out in public
areas because this was all happened on a
sidewalk on a very public
Street yeah there's
um there's two local um local um
constituents that have come to me
recently this is in actually some of it
was during election time um one of them
was actually um attacked by a dog um not
on a leash and nothing has been done um
ripped the whole back of her leg so I
just um I haven't really um spent time
on this and hearing now this another
story here that there just doesn't seem
to be a um even a legal pathway that
these things are taken care of um it's
it's quite concerning so thank you for
your testimony and I'm sorry what took
place thank you very much I appreciate
that um so I I do see that we have in
statute um musling and restraining
dogs and that there are penalties for
vicious
offense um $100 for first vicious
offense $400 for second or subsequent
vicious offense was anybody fined in
this uh in this attack that happened I
was told that the owner was fined
um not to be flip but the dog doesn't
care if it gets fined or not it's still
going to bite the next dog or the next
person that's going by if they have a
bike history um that's the bottom
line representive King thank you again
Madam chair um one more question yes um
let's say this bill were to get passed
and municipalities have the authority
now to muzzle dogs um it it sounds good
the idea of muzzling that dog but would
you feel comfortable having your dog
muzzled as well and all dogs being
muzzled because I'm not sure how the
municipality would would create
something that would only muzzle the bad
dogs you
know well dogs that have a reported bite
history okay so you in your idea in your
ideal the the M municipalities would
create regulations for only dogs um that
have a bite history to be muzzled right
okay I don't mean to have every dog
muzzled in public but if you have a
known aggressive dog y yep okay but just
so just so we're aware I think if if I
understand it correctly this might allow
for the opportunity for a municipality
to muzzle all dogs that that is that you
don't think that would happen Okay no
Okay I do not I don't think that's
necessary
but so so the whole premise is that if
that dog had been muzzled because it
already had a bite history it would have
been prevented and that and that's my
take on it representative Howard thank
you madam chair um so in this in that
scenario who is keeping track of the
vicious dogs is where is the database
that that would keep track of dogs that
need to be muzzled well I would assume
the Animal control officer so you have
one now there is one now correct yes she
did call me and speak with me um
so okay any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much and I'm really sorry that this
happened to you um appreciate that yeah
thank you for coming and tell tell in
your
story uh I call let's see here we've got
Daniel
you I need you to speak into the mic and
um turn it on there's a little button
there
there you
go thank you good morning good morning
uh first I'd like to thank
the commission leader a chairperson and
members of the committee for allowing me
to expect my opinion I'm representing
myself my name is Daniel doam I live in
the town of gilmont and I've been a
resident of bellnap County all my life
which is 81 years
uh there was a house in the dog in the
house when I was born and there'll be
one in the house when I
pass uh I own hunting dogs hting
dogs and uh house pets if you want to
say that this thing is kind of vague to
me a lot of
it um comes to morals ethics common
sense and you can't legislate that but
uh you know nothing is said about
hunting dogs herting dogs you can't have
hunting dogs wearing muzzles in the
woods they're just going to get caught
up
and uh you know it's going to be a
disaster certain muzzles don't allow
them to back a hunting dog needs to
bark um same with
hering they don't need to necessarily
bite
livestock uh especially sheep but with
cattle sometimes you have an honor
animal and a little nip will
get them going but they can't do this
with muzzles on
so without you know the way it's worded
I I'm just cuz I'm afraid how it's going
to come out but it also would seem to me
uh if you had to regulate
this uh I don't know how you in a
municipality or whatever that it would
be Statewide just like the leash laws
not each town or what whatever different
uh so I'm opposed to as written and as I
said because of being H having hunting
dogs hurting dogs and just a dog around
the I live in the country I don't have a
neighbor in sight of my house I like
having a
watchdog and one that isn't necessarily
muzzled he can't do his job if he's
muzzled as far as hurting it's when you
got sheep and
cattle uh the biggest problems they have
is during lambing time or cing time and
with coyotes
Predators uh a hurting dog can't do his
thing if he's
muzzled and I guess that's all I got to
say and I'll try to answer anybody's
questions if they have
them uh do you think that a a
um do you think that a a a hurting dog
or a hunting
dog that a city council might want to
muzzle
them I'm not sure I don't how this is
you know all going to play out but uh I
have my fears and I'd want to see a
better description of you know the law
before I would support
it okay thank you representa H Haskins
thank you madam chair and thank you Mr
dockham for coming today to testify we
appreciate your presence here would you
be more comfortable with the bill if it
expressly said that having once bitten
another animal or a person that they
should be muzzled if they're on a
public
sidewalk no not no in public as what
happened to this unfortunate situation
but you know I I don't think there's
anything in there that exempts hunting
dogs or herting dogs and uh so therefore
you know that would be my main
opposition so the Once Bitten part sorry
follow up Madam chair oh yes sure the
Once Bitten part doesn't reach you
as no uh as I said I've had dogs all my
life both hunting and herting I've never
had one that was ugly with people yeah I
wouldn't personally keep an ugly dog all
right my house dog and what I call Watch
Dog would probably not bite anyone but
surely would you know try to deter them
and they're a deterrent yes for for that
type of thing but I I I guess I could
say the cattle dog I got now if somebody
started to grab me or rough housee me
that dog would intervene but otherwise
it would not sure
understood thank
you okay thank you um represent Scully
um grber I'm sorry would you like to
take your seat uh representative Howard
you had a question yes thank you madam
chair so so it would be more clear to
you or it would feel more um more
appropriate to to classify it by
exemptions of of certain types of dogs
rather than to speci specify dogs that
had already been deemed a
danger right well I I you know of course
hunting dogs and hurting dogs really
aren't out in the
public but I still would like to see
some kind of wording to that effect I
mean if it has I don't know how you
would word it any municipality or
whatever uh they had to be muzzled that
wouldn't bother me I don't take my
hunting dogs to town my hurting dogs
either so but you know uh to me the way
it's
written uh could be being up to any kind
of
interpretation okay any other
questions yes seeing uh representative
miby so just as a clarification of the
way that the bill Works uh there are
certain powers that the state reserves
to itself in fact Mo s the powers of law
are reserved by the state unless they're
directly granted to
communities and which means that the
issue here is that without our giving uh
municipalities permission they can't
make any rules about
musling uh what this bill would be doing
is just giving towns the permission to
do that and then if your town were to uh
create an ordinance you would have have
the opportunity to uh participate in
your Town's decision about creating that
or
ordinance so uh does that change your
your
um feeling about the bill no I think
that it should be like the leash laws
okay and otherw
Statewide okay thank you okay any other
questions thank you sir for coming this
morning and testifying thank you so much
for coming and testifying uh the
committee has no more questions for you
and uh we appreciate your time well
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to express myself
sure uh the next person to come speak is
Bobby
Williams good morning Mr Williams
agriculture hello thank you for having
me um my name is Bobby Williams I'm a
city counselor on the Keane city council
so um after uh Deb's dog suffered this
unfortunate attack she came to me um to
ask that the city do something about uh
vicious dogs that had a record of
attacking other dogs and so um I I did
bring it uh as a suggested ordinance to
the city council and um when we were in
committee um you know there was a lot of
positive feedback on the idea but um the
um that uh there was just a Twist in the
way the law was written that that meant
that we weren't not empowered to to do
um do this musling and that is that um
you know uh representative Bixby uh
mentioned um that there is you know
existing existing language about
restraining drugs and and one would
think and I thought at the time that
that would apply to musling um however
since there's another section of the law
um that talks about a rabies outbreak
and says that in the event of a rabies
outbreak um municipalities can order
dogs to be muzzled um because that
section of law talks about musling um it
was assumed that um you know that was
what we were allowed to do for musling
and that that uh superseded um the law
about restraining in the other section
of the law so um I don't think it was
ever intentionally written to uh exclude
the uh you know a municipality's um
ability to use musling as a restraint
but because this other section of the
law regarding rabies um came in um that
changed the meaning such that we were
not able to um pass an ordinance to uh
address um you know this concern that a
lot of people have expressed about um
dogs that have a history of of attacking
other dogs in public um we did
subsequently you know looking for what
we could do um there
were uh you know some finds that that we
we raised the fine for a a vicious a
vicious dog um attacking another we
raised that uh from from $50 to the
maximum of $100 um I don't really feel
that that's an effective way to prevent
this kind of thing um but it was it was
what we were able to do um and so we you
know we kind of feel like um you know
being being a city we should we should
be empowered to protect the public
safety of our citizens and that this
this is preventing us from doing that
and so um you all have a letter on your
desk from our mayor um that expresses uh
you know it was a unanimous vote uh by
the city council to send you this letter
expressing support for for this measure
so um with that um having explained uh
represent happened thank you madam chair
and thank you for coming today um you
might be the exact person to talk to on
this issue um you we just heard from the
previous testifier that there's some
fear that um the the the the law might
be too broad and then a city could
create an ordinance that's too broad and
next thing you know you're affecting
people that live out in the country and
their hunting dogs and their guard dogs
and stuff like that um can you explain
to us how you would create uh create or
craft an ordinance that would help to
address the issue at hand without being
overly
broad um
thank you that that's a good question uh
first of all um we would we would make
the uh the ordinance apply to dogs that
are in public so if your dog is on
private hunting land um you know this
this doesn't apply uh second
um I don't really want to
make this uh a permanent ban for dogs
you know dogs that have an offense to
never be allowed to go uh unmuzzled
again I might say you know 18 months or
or two years um but eventually you know
even Fierce dogs get older and you know
we might we might want to give them a
second chance and then if if um if they
do bite again then you know maybe that
would be a more a more permanent thing
um but I would also say uh you know to
the gentleman's Point um you know every
every municipality is different has has
different needs uh you know the needs of
of keen with you know crowded sidewalks
dogs walking around they're they're
different from um you know a place a
place out in the country
and you know this is an opportunity for
the municipal leaders the city
councilors or Selectmen to you know
respond to you know what are the needs
of their particular
area and um I would also say that
um I know that dog owners are very
passionate about their dogs they love
their dogs you know we all love dogs um
and in the event that this would come up
before uh the city council or or any um
Municipal organization um every uh every
local lawmaker is going to be hearing
from their constituents about what what
they think about this which is great and
that's that's how it's supposed to work
um but I would I would be very surprised
if uh you know a city council um was
particularly heavy-handed on this
because we know that there is a lot of
um constituent interest in things like
hunting dogs and making sure that
everyone's rights are maintained and um
I I don't think this is this is a case
where anyone would be eager to overstep
but at the same time you know we do have
a duty to our public to make sure that
um they will be safe in the streets from
from a dog that might attack thank you
very
much any other questions representative
Penza uh thank you madam
chair um looking over the legislation
it's literally just adding in one word
and um and I think you've explained it
Al in regards
with we already have law on the books
that's giving um the local governing
bodies the right of course for licensing
and restraining of dogs as it deems
reasonable
so
if
um that's already all in here so I I
guess I the concerns that people are
making they don't seem to to me to be
valid only because we've already you
already have the authority to to do
restraining so um through your local
ordinances I'd like to ask about what
first you know there's a now it's a $100
fine what's second offense what's third
offense when is a
dog taken away from an owner if it
continues to not just bite and attack uh
another animal but I I my more of my
concern is the public so when does that
that happen how many offenses does it
take before someone
learns I I don't have that information
um but uh you know the goal here would
be to prevent that second representative
penzo we have um RSA 466 colon
31-a which establishes penalties for uh
dogs and cats that are yeah well musling
and restraining dogs and uh it it cites
$100 for the first vicious offense $400
for the second or subsequent vicious
offense um and then there is um
opportunity for the town or city clerk
uh
to you know assess that and collect
monies but um it it should also have the
cases disposed of in a district or
municipal court so at some point it's
supposed to go to court as I understand
the statute but um in any case okay good
I just wanted to answer your question
that's great so then a court could make
a decision if okay that dog is you know
deemed as far as I understand okay thank
you um represent Gruber you had a
question yes uh thank you madam chair uh
and thank you for coming to testify
uh this appears this the what we're
looking at here is an enabling
legislation so that local government
through their due process can decide
whether they would like to adopt a
musling ordinance um right now you
currently have authority to take away a
dog
uh my question is is does this give you
another valuable tool along the way
before taking away a dog it seems to me
that uh providing you a broader toolbox
before you get to more serious action
would actually uh be well received by
Community can you comment on that uh
yeah I would say that's that's
absolutely the intention here um you
know we want uh nobody nobody wants to
see a dog taken away no one wants to see
a dog put down um but this is you know
something that we can do that uh creates
you know a measure of protection for the
public without having to take those
extreme steps thank you any other
questions represent H Haskins thank you
madam chair and I'm not sure Mr Williams
is if you're the person to answer this
question the bill doesn't say after one
bite so um would you be comfortable in
your uh City to leave that up to
local government is
there I mean we keep talking about it
after one bite but the bill doesn't say
that so would that be sufficient for you
if musling were added as this bill
currently
reads uh yeah I believe um I don't have
the language in front of me but you know
the intention was always to apply to
vicious dogs which are defined in
statute as doesn't say that
either well in our in our city council
deliberations we have always talked
about this as applying to Vici vicious
dogs which are defined as dogs that have
bitten represent yeah just uh for your
information the reference stat in
statute for a vicious dog is 466 colum
31 if I may ask does that mean that that
doesn't have to be in this particular
bill because it's in the it statute
musling is not uh listed as a remedy
46631 so the definition of vicious is
here but it doesn't and but the remedy
is a range of things from uh fines to
confiscation U musling is not listed as
a remedy in 466a thank you thank you any
other questions representative Howard
thank you madam chair this just sort of
briefly um I know that in other towns
and cities they have allow musling for
dog breeds certain breeds of dogs and um
that that would not be part of your
ordinance would it no I wouldn't be
opposed to any um any breed based uh
musling ordinance um this is this is
behavior based and I think that's how it
should be thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much for taking the time to come and and
uh testify to our committee this morning
thank you very much I would like to call
Kyle
Baker good morning um my name is Kyle
Baker I'm with the law from WTH young
and Pignatelli and I'm here on behalf of
the New Hampshire Wildlife Federation
New Hampshire Wildlife Federation is a
92-year-old nonpartisan nonprofit
organization that advocates for the
ability to hunt fish and trap in New
Hampshire um we're here to talk some of
our concerns have already been outlined
by Mr doam um we're mainly concerned
with the potential unintended
consequences and effects on hunting dogs
um hunting dogs are currently Exempted
um under 466 um 31 regarding um sort of
the leash law is the atlarge um
requirements that a dog be on a leash um
when it's off of the owner's property
hunting dogs are Exempted from there um
hunting dogs are highly trained um
otherwise no one would be hunting with
them because they would be ineffective
so um we you know there's some concerns
um that we have because of that um 466
also um as we've it's already been
mentioned here um delves into what the
definition of a a vicious dog would be
um talks about specifically mentions a
dog that is out of control um whether or
not it's under the on the leash um it
doesn't specify it says if it bites
another dog um another domestic animal
or game animal it would be considered
and it allows law enforcement to seize
the dog um in a court order to determine
what what um what could happen there so
um understanding that um there's a
desire to move something away to um stop
a attack having to happen before the law
kicks in to do something about it um we
would suggest you know adding some more
specificity around it um it sounds like
Keen wants to do a fantastic thoughtful
job of designing an ordinance but uh
we'd feel more comfortable if there was
a few more guardrails in place around um
how uh musling would be impacted um take
licensing muzzling and restraining as
it's listed in 466 39 are three very
different things um and have very
different effects on the dog so um
potentially an idea might be removing
musling from 466 39 and coming up with a
more specific um parameter along the
lines of saying that a municipality May
create an ordinance requiring uh
representative Haskins you talked about
it um requiring a dog that has a history
of biting other dogs um to be muzzled um
and coming up with something a little
bit more uh specific around there I
think would definitely address our
concerns um but happy to work with the
committee of the sponsor and The
Advocates or answer any questions that
folks may
have represent Bixby do you think uh
this uh a provision for musling would be
better located in 46631 or 31a I think
in you know 31 is uh is pretty has a lot
of specifics I think it's like a through
t or something along those lines there's
a lot of specific so maybe making it a
remedy for the court uh when the court
is is issuing an order on what what
happens in those cases that a court
order may include uh requiring that dog
to be muzzled when it's in a public
place um allows for some more due
process and ability to to folks to make
their case as well rather than just a
blanket
ordinance uh go ahead so uh so I I'm I'm
concerned about the of of about a case
having to go through the court because
it seems like this is something that
could be done better at the
administrative level Within in the
municipality rather than requiring it to
go through the court cycle which can be
very long and drawn out and expensive
yeah no uh I I guess I'm sort of
agnostic on where where it happens as
far as that I think as long as there's
some sort of specificity that says you
know if a municipality or you know the
city of Keane since they're here I'll
use them as an example and saying we
don't want we want if a dog has a
history of biting other dogs if that dog
wants to operate on Main Street um and
they want to be walked on Main Street it
has to have a muzzle okay versus just
saying if someone is out on Town land
with their dogs it has to have a muzzle
on it um my reading and I I don't think
it obviously I don't think it's the
intent of the legislation to be Broad
and capture all dogs but if I want to
use my hunting dogs on Town pasture land
um the town May approve bird hunting on
its pasture land and I'm using my dogs
on pasture land and they have an
ordinance in place that says um all dogs
in public must be have a Melana and I
don't think that's any body's intent um
but the language here would allow for
something along those lines and that's
why we have the concern so as long as
there's some sort of guard rails whether
that's a remedy for the court or just
saying that a municipality can pass an
ordinance regarding a dog with a
violence violence history um something
along those lines would be amenable to
us followup yeah so uh so the key thing
would be to make sure that the that what
whatever we pass in uh indicates that
musling is
a remedy for a dog that is behaving
viciously yeah exactly okay thank
questions seeing none thank you very
much for coming
LeBlanc is there a Nancy LeBlanc from
Dunbarton
good morning good morning welcome to
environment and
agriculture please let us know your name
where you're from and let us know what
you'd like to tell us um Nancy
Hampshire and uh I didn't know I was
coming out to talk oh okay would you
prefer not to say
anything uh well I'm Debbie's
mother and
uh she went through a lot
happened and
uh I do believe that when a dog
attacks for the first time the second it
should be muzzled it should be
muzzled that's all I can
say okay any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for
coming up and speaking with
us uh the last pink card I have if
anybody else wishes to speak Please send
up a pink card uh on this
hb250 uh the last person I have to speak
good
morning good morning chair Aaron members
of the committee my name is Stacy oer
I'm the New England government relations
manager for the American Kennel Club
we're a recognized expert in K9 Health
breeding training and responsible dog
ownership I wanted to comment um this
morning on Senate excuse me House Bill
250 and note that this committee
entertained a bill last session for
instance where similar uh issue had
happened with dangerous dogs and asking
for additional tools um the American
Kennel Club believes that there should
be a response based on the deed not the
breed of the dog and unfortunately
across the country our department does
see on occasion where a county or a city
or an ordinance in response to a a
particular attack May adopt
discriminatory language uh based on a
breed whether it's a pitbull or maybe it
was a German shepherd and what we know
is that when there is that type of
discrimination for instance uh what can
happen to dog owners is they can be
discriminated against even in their
rental insurance or their homeowners
insurance where insurers will say oh you
want a ro you own a Rottweiler we either
won't provide insurance or we're going
to escalate the premium even though your
particular dog may not have any
dangerous Behavior so in looking at the
bill I think it f fails to recognize
that the attempt here the is to
associate muzzling requirements with a
dog that has been identified as
dangerous I will say that the
international Municipal Lawyers
Association has model ordinance language
on how to go about identifying a
potentially dangerous dog what is a
dangerous dog it has all sorts of due
process protections it's quite lengthy
um I'm happy to share it with committee
but in looking at the RSA uh
specifically that you were referring to
that New Hampshire has on the books um
which is
466 colon
31 it defines vicious dog under
two um G if whether alone or in a pack
with other dogs it bites attacks or
prays on game animals domestic animals
fowl or human beings so that's a a a
broad uh definition but there's no
procedure or process for
identifying um for the town to identify
or label a particular dog as dangerous
and then even monitor their behavior on
whether there's subsequent attacks or
incidents where the owner uh failed to
comply with the language in your statute
that says they could have an order to
restrain the dog I think it's arguable
whether restrain includes muzzling but
likewise just putting mu ing in here may
not be sufficient um your statute also
allows taking custody of the animal and
your hearing testimony where that may
not be the really the even the second
line of action that you'd like to take
so I just wanted to note that some
states have statutes that really provide
some guidance to municipalities around
an ordinance that they might want to
consider adopting and some of the uh
tools that are included are not just
muzzling but I thought I would just name
a few um like I said almost a statutory
road map to help cities and um uh towns
to identify you they may want to adopt
an ordinance that there needs to be a
way to identify a dog once it's labeled
as dangerous so requiring a microchip or
a tattoo or something of that nature so
you can track it um might also require
remedial action that the owner go to
behavior training uh with the dog so
that that behavior is not
repeated um it may outline ways to
humanely restrain the dog other than
just saying when it's on when it's out
off your property you have to um have it
muzzled and even proof of insurance
against claims of loss damage injury to
people animals or property so these are
all the kinds of Provisions that
actually put into place I think a a
public safety mechanis ISM to ensure
that someone that owns a dangerous dog
is held accountable um the last thing
I'll say is that the statute appears to
not address instances where and
typically uh it comes down to in
identifying a dog is dangerous whether
or not the dog was provoked and I don't
see any language in your Statute in that
regard so uh oftentimes in state law
you'll
see okay if there was a bite injury or
whatnot were these exceptions in place
uh was the person trespassing clear
that's not the incident here uh was the
dog provoked have you ever seen young
kids go by a vehicle and stick sticks
into a window to try and provoke you
know provoke an animal in there and
tease it um so I'm happy to provide that
kind of language if the committee wanted
to look at what other states have had
almost as some kind of goalposts or
whatever for their statute so thank you
for your attention I'd be delighted to
see that kind of language
personally any questions for Miss obber
um representative Howard thank you madam
chair um so would you would you make an
exception for a dog that was provoked
but went but did you know did great
bodily harm to another pet or or a
person so typically what we see is there
could be when I talked about the due
process a procedure where um the dog
owner would get a complaint and in short
order there would be a hearing of Select
board members or sometimes it's even the
Animal control officer themselves in
trying to hear from both sides of the
story and making a determination whether
or not the dog has been labeled
dangerous and frequently there's even a
process for taking that label off as you
heard earlier sometimes after
remediation behavior training maybe that
label is no longer appropriate um so I'm
happy to provide language around that
process that could local authorities
could use representative uh Bixby yeah
so um I I would love to see that that
model language do you have a sense of
whether it would make more sense to
include that in uh 431 or 431a or in uh
439 which the current bill uses uh um so
466 colon
31a in my experience from an attorney
drafting standpoint I've seen it
typically under the authority of
municipalities so under the statute that
allows municipalities to license dogs
and gives them all of that kind of
control because that's where the lo you
know it's local laws that typically are
where uh control of dogs takes place um
you already have over in another section
however the provisions you know around
addressing dogs as a menace nuisance or
uh vicious dog
so I can't answer specifically for New
Hampshire but you have two places I
think where it logically could go
okay thank you any other questions from
the committee seeing none thank you very
much for coming and testifying on this
bill do representative Scully please
take your seat uh you can bring the blue
sheet with you if you like bring the
blue sheet with you if you like for
um okay let's see here I'm going to say
we have on the online port portal we
have seven people in support of this
sheet we have three people in support
and three people in
opposition and with that I'm going to
close out the hearing for 200 uh
hp250 and I want to thank everybody who
showed up today to come and testify on
that
bill um okay moving right along we have
at 11:00 here uh HB
424 directing the Department of
Agriculture markets and food to create
fors for businesses to request
information about service animals and
establishing a committee to study the
protection of business owners from
requests to accommodate customers with
animals so um before we have um our
start our hearing I did request um our
committee researcher to give us provide
us some information on state and federal
laws governing service animals so that
we are familiar with um you know what
what the different requirements are um
the questions that I asked her to
research were what does New Hampshire
law require regarding service animals
what does federal law require regarding
service animals do service animals have
to be
registered is there a mechanism to
determine the legitimacy of a purported
service animal is it legally permissible
to ask a service animal owner for
documentation to prove the service
animal status is there a difference
between a service animal and an
emotional support animal what species of
animals are accepted as service animals
what are businesses required to do
regarding service animals and are there
any locations where use of service
animals are prohibited so I'm just going
to pass copies of this report out to you
you can look at it at uh after this
hearing to become more familiar with uh
how we deal with this and then
hearing does everybody have a copy of
the bill by the
four does everybody have a copy of the
um I am going to open up the hearing for
HB
424 and I invite representative
Stringham to introduce the bill to our
committee good morning and thank you for
coming good morning uh thank you madam
chair uh my name is Jerry Stringham I
represent Grafton County Third District
uh which includes the town of Lincoln
and Woodstock and
Easton uh an area filled with uh lots of
restaurants and hotels brings in lots of
visitors uh not from uh just New England
but from all over the country and in
fact all over the world
uh so uh uh the issue uh with this bill
uh is particularly uh significant for
for those in my district uh House Bill
424 is called directing the Department
of Agriculture markets and food to
create forms for businesses to request
information about service animals and
establishing a committee to study the
protection of business owners from
requests to accommodate customers with
fraudulent or untrained service animals
so uh you in in part I'm I'm sure you've
all experienced and we know that there's
uh how critical service animals are for
our disabled population and how much uh
how the uh fed federal laws require
access for people who who need a service
animal to function normally uh and uh we
also know that there's uh been uh
widespread uh uh distribution ution of
artificial vests and things that people
are taking advantage of of the service
animal requirements by saying their dog
is a service animal when in reality it's
either a pet or perhaps just a comfort
animal of some type and it's gotten to
the to the uh to the level where it's a
major problem uh uh perhaps for for all
businesses but uh particularly for
restaurants and
hotels um so HB 424 deals with the
individuals
misrepresenting uh the service animal
status of their pets so they can access
uh restaurants and a hotel in a way uh
this this was brought to me by local uh
hotels originally uh but um uh groups
like New Hampshire uh lodging and
Restaurant Association and individual
restaurant owners said this is not this
is a daily occurrence where animals that
that uh most certainly don't appear to
be service animals are being represented
that way um I'm glad you you've done the
uh the research you've had uh we're very
very very restricted on what we can do
in the state of New Hampshire uh without
violating the Americans with
Disabilities Act so uh part part of this
process uh was um you know to seek out
those that we would need uh uh support
of and input from to come up with the
right rules for example I met with uh
Sean Lock who is in the Attorney
General's office with over five years of
experience in Disability Policy and
there's people here from the disability
rights Center uh and uh involved in that
area as well as talking with the the Bia
and uh the New Hampshire um lodging and
so the the the laws and and disclosures
largely address the importance rights to
those granted with need and disservice
animal blind is the most common but
there are there are other ones that are
that are done as well but the the
federal laws themselves there are no
real requirements for in my view no real
requirements to qualify a service animal
they don't have to be professionally
trained you as an individual can certify
that your pet is a service animal and
that it it takes uh it takes over a
function that you need taken care of
because of some disability so an example
of that might be I hurt my back and I
teach my dog that if I accidentally drop
a tennis ball that he'll go pick it up
and bring it back to me and so I don't
have to bend over and pick it up so
that's an a function so it's essentially
playing uh catch or fetch with a with an
animal
that that could legitimately say that I
could represent that my dog is a is a
service dog with something that minor
that's part of federal
law um and um so and we're also
restricted on how much we can ask you're
allowed to ask if it's not obvious what
the what the uh dis ability is that you
have you can ask what is the disability
that's uh being taken care of and is
your is your pet a service animal those
are the only two questions and uh in my
uh experience even you know lowlevel or
floral Level Restaurant workers and uh
are are familiar with that and follow
that um the uh I did provide a copy of
uh this notice uh and there's there's
copies for everybody this is available
uh from the governor's Commission on
disability which says it it's illegal to
misrepresent a pet as a service animal
um and you know G given given the
definition of a Ser service Animal by
federal law I I don't think we're we've
going to see any uh any people you know
being fine $1,200 successfully uh with
that but still this this has been
somewhat helpful for people who come in
and try to check in a hotel or or make a
reservation and claim their dog as a
service dog and they just at least have
this up the idea of uh uh having a form
or something that could be filled out is
also to put in uh have it be directly
visible to people at the point when
they're asking uh for service for for
Mis branded animal uh what their
expectations are things like if you do
have a a service pet you're expected to
keep them under control at all time
you're expected to be in in in almost
all circumstances in your presence so uh
these are the things that uh the hotels
and restaurants say at least there's
some dialogue uh that can can occur
before uh the pet Co pet uh is is
granted access to the service
uh the conversations that I've had um uh
the the the challenges with the for is
it sounds like you're asking extra
things for um people with legitimate
service animals and you know we're
really have to deal with both sides of
this we can't this anything we do can't
violate uh the Ada as it exists today
and the
um uh the conversations with the
Attorney General's office basic one of
the when you're checking into a hotel or
making a reservation normally you are
filling out a form of some type
electronically and uh at the point where
you you could ask whether they plan to
bring a pet uh that would be um it would
be reasonable to um at least ask these
two questions and then have the other
information about having a pet at at the
facility
um uh in plain sight and and reacted to
it so um you know uh you know just given
given the uh uh the restrictions of the
Ada um uh you know when when I drafted
this bill I was thinking both
restaurants and
hotels uh hotels very commonly have have
you fill out a form of some type to stay
there so that would be less of a stretch
to try to uh uh increase these notice
Provisions with without
um uh without in any way violating the
very important rights that we give our
disabled so um uh you know I I believe
it's it's reasonable and possible to do
that and uh and and perhaps reduce some
of the chaos uh that's going on in some
of these facilities and uh at least at
least one restaurant I know of when when
they shut down uh talked about uh the
the annoyance of of uh having misbranded
animals being part of their customer
base and what they did and that was
just
uh it's not not not fair for them either
so
um uh I guess with that I'll open up and
see if you have any questions okay thank
you before we take questions I'd like my
U members to take their
seats thank you for waiting and being
patient representative King thank you
madam chair and thank you for the bill
and testifying and taking
questions um I I like easy solutions and
I'm trying to think of I at least I
think I thought of a solution that to me
seems simple and that is like with the
disabled and they have the blue placards
that they hang up on their uh rearview
mirror or on their license plate and
pretty much all the businesses support
that with some extra parking spaces
nobody needs to explain to anybody else
why they have that blue placard uh it's
private business but it's accepted that
there it is um why can't there be
something similar like that for dogs
which is you know you get your doctor's
written permission slip to have one and
then you get your dog from an accredited
whatever and and long story short you
eventually get like a state issued green
placard or something that goes around
the dog's neck or is attached to the
back you normally they wear these vests
it seems like there's a big sticker on
there and then that way everybody can
just easily recognize yep that is a
certified trained service dog you know
and yeah there might be some fraud about
somebody who like carries that dog with
them it's really their dad's dog but
they take it with them to the store um
that might happen some but generally
speaking that placard is going to be
pretty difficult to come by and the it
would greatly reduce the amount of Fraud
and Abuse around that instead of having
to bother or put a burden on business
owners to have to fill out paperwork or
anything like that it's just yep I see
that Dog's good come on in nope that dog
doesn't have a placard can't come in
what are your thoughts on that uh I mean
I would love it but it's violation of
the Americans with Disabilities Act
which specifically says you can't have
any licensing type requirements for that
they don't they they can't uh you can't
require them to be registered you can't
require them to um have completed formal
training or have a c certificate like
that that's my understanding of of the
Ada is that's that's not not um we we
can't do that they do have those vests
and little cards that people do but you
can order them if somebody has a
computer look up on Amazon right now you
can buy them and and put them on that's
about all that exists and so um that I
would have loved that solution if that
if it was something that everybody could
agree to followup follow up um okay I'm
I'm not familiar with what you're
referring to but I'm just curious what I
mean do you know the reason why that is
because I mean it's not a hippo viol
people don't consider it a hippo
violation to put a blue placard up on
your car you're telling the whole world
that you've got a disability but we
still don't consider that a hippo
violation do you under do you know why
the federal government thinks it would
be a hippo violation to have a placard
on your dog or it's not a hippo
violation or an ADA violation why why is
that do did do they provide a reasoning
you know I think when they created
created this U my understanding is they
just felt like it would be too
burdensome uh a requirement for those
who need service animals to have to go
through that process and so it's written
into the uh Ada at least one of them is
one of the documents that I've they've
given you and uh there are other people
here who can who who live with uh making
sure that the lives of our disabled are
highquality ones that are speaking as
well that uh both understand the
understand the needs for our businesses
but also the Urgent protection of the
disabled as well sorry um thank you and
I only have one pink card so if anybody
wants to speak please make sure you send
Penza thank you madam chair
um I just had a question in regards with
the notice that you um had talked about
so so this is basically um the
businesses have been putting this have
been posting this and you're saying it's
been
successful I think I think they they
found they were getting some um it was
helpful it was helpful not not adequate
but better than better than uh when they
did when I was first approached the
first time they did not know about this
notice so and then you know said let me
know how this works and then said well
yeah it's helpful in having a discussion
when somebody comes in with clearly a
non-service animal which is most of the
time an animal shows up at these
businesses it's usually not really a
service animal because they recognize
the service animals almost right away
given their temperament and training and
so on followup followup um there's a
there's a gentleman that comes to our
church that um has a a service dog um he
was in the military and
has this is I can't tell you if if he
could do this all day long because it
really really bothers him um
this fakeness that's out there um
because it it hurts it hurts their work
now
um You can tell the difference really
you can by the ones that you're buying
online which if everybody hasn't um seen
that it's it's really easy to get
um and slap it on an animal and act as
if it's their service animal so um maybe
there's a a way to show um information
wise of that
legitimacy like ones that you know I
know you can see where his dog came from
um uh it's credible organization that is
teaching training service dogs matching
all of that kind of stuff versus I mean
you can tell from the criteria that's on
his animal and you're not allowed to
touch his animal so that's what I'm is
there a way like I I know this notice
piece but is there more that could be
done in a sense to say okay um we know
that this is not legit but this is do
you know what I'm saying like in just um
having having that be out
there well I think we have you know we
have some good people to ask that about
I know that you know I've been been
frustrated by the exact language of the
Americans with Disabilities Act
provision here and um you know I trust
that they put them there for a good
reason but it it it is creating some
chaos and and
um you my understanding of the federal
law is that there's no requirement that
the dog have anything on them in in any
way and uh it's really a a a self
it's the the individual himself who says
whether it's a service dog and what
disability uh it helps helps him or her
with thank you for the question do you
know do you know if there's any uh um
um impetus to change federal law the Ada
law to to allow
for any kind
of better designation of service animals
you know I I would I would consider it a
reasonable you know partial outcome of
this process is to ask the federal
government to do something and what that
might be um but as far as I know there's
no
pending uh nothing uh okay currently uh
in the loop okay representative wheeler
you had a question and then over to this
side Gully thank you madam chair thank
you representative Stringham for taking
my question good to see you as well my
question is representative King asked
about the blue placard which I thought
was a good question and I am too
frustrated to hear about the
Ada's lack of thoughtfulness when it
comes to these issues but I'm wondering
if the blue form is not compliant with
Ada standards is the form that's
outlined here compliant with Ada
standards as far as you understand I you
I'm you know having had the
conversations with with uh uh
individuals uh who are in this room and
with Sean Sean Lock I I don't think the
form uh uh I I think they would have
concerns um that it's too far-reaching
at this point uh and um
uh I feel very very good about the
experience and skill levels the those
people bring to the process um and um
uh you know ultimately it's really uh
you know for businesses to want to have
engage uh uh more with you know their
their important customers
about what to expect when they come to
the to the uh uh to their
establishment um you know we really need
the uh Attorney General's office to kind
of set those bounds you know based on
Federal and State law so um uh which is
which is why I did that uh Outreach
after submitting this bill so um you
know part part of the bill also talks
about having a study committee uh and um
uh you know to work out any details but
part part of that is um part of the
reason why focused on the lodging is
because interaction between uh an
establishment and their customer using a
form uh to make a reservation is common
whereas it's fairly incommon for
restaurants followup Madam shair
followup yep thank you so you kind of
got to my follow-up question there and
your answer would you be amenable to
removing the first section of the bill
and making it simply a study committee
to study this issue over the course of
the summer and come back with a
potential solution having worked with
the attorney General's office and other
stakeholders on this
issue and hopefully this esteemed
committee absolutely yeah absolutely
okay representative Scully then Howard
thank you Madame chair and um good
morning thank you for putting this
before as I think this is something that
should be considered I I would think
that um businesses assume a liability
when somebody walks in the door with
their dog and presents it as a a service
animal and I think think this is a good
idea to May at least get them to certify
they may be lying but at least you have
on record that they are I was wondering
if there was any potential for offering
relief to businesses from potential
liability if they go to the trouble of
getting this completed and the person
lied to them and their dog ends up
biting somebody while they're in
there uh you know I I I I guess most of
the businesses I deal with just you know
don't want the hassle so it's hard to
kick out somebody and there's dogs who
come in and eat Foods off other people's
plates and uh uh and uh uh you know even
get so excited they uh you know p on the
floor or something like that and Y um
and sometimes even asking those people
to leave in those circumstances is uh is
not
um is not uh very uh helpful or easy for
them it doesn't doesn't give you good
ratings on Yelp let me put it that
way so um you know they I mean there is
assumed liability by in the part of the
pet owner if the pet does do damage at
the restaurant excuse me could you pull
the mic a little closer to you sure
sorry about that thank you so there is
there is assumed liability on the part
of the part of the pets assuming you
know who the person you know but um I
don't know of too many cases where
where um these businesses really want to
pursue something like that
so but thank you for the question okay
representative Howard then Bixby then
Penza thank you madam chair um so my
understanding is that your hands are
tied by the Ada laws including you can't
even ask what the disability is or what
the service dog provides so you you can
ask what the disability is oh I've I've
always had push back from the I you know
I don't know what would happen if they
don't
answer and whether you could you you
just say is this a service dog and what
is the disability and those are the only
two questions you can ask okay so my
question was about the form whether or
not it it probes to more deeply than it
than it's allowed to and also um I
wanted to sort of um piggyback on to uh
representative Wheeler's idea of having
this be a study with part of the outcome
being um a a an application to the
federal um lawmakers about changing
loosening this up because I do think
there is a broad abuse of this um
designation of
pets thank you um I appreciate that
repres
Biby yeah um I just wanted to uh get a
little clarification are dogs the only
uh species that are allowed to be
uh no there's other animals although
dogs are the by far the most
common but I think I've seen miniature
horses are even in the specifically
listed in the Ada uh documents but what
else is I'm not sure thank you I've
actually seen helper
monkeys yep yeah um representative
Penza uh thank you madam chair uh thank
you for taking my question I have a
um what can a business owner do now so I
have personally witnessed and received
phone calls from constituents um
actually some that came before I was
elected um first term and where dog ate
food off of um another guests um it it
was awful that um I was actually at a
restaurant where the dog defecated on
the floor I mean I just
where um but that the this dog that did
that when I was there did not have like
a jacket on or anything it was just you
know this is my service
animal where right now in the law um is
there any um outlet for a business owner
well I don't know if I'm the best person
to answer I do know that the
establishments have the absolute right
to ask any anybody who's brought a
service animal in uh to if that is not
being properly controlled and behaved to
to leave immediately uh they are also
required to offer the services to them
without the dog if the dog leaves um but
so that's part of what's in uh um uh law
whether they're uh whether there's
they're eligible for any Financial
restitution through whatever civil
process might be available I don't know
okay thank you okay representative
Skully I'm sorry guber I'm getting
everybody mixed up today great thank you
grber thank you m chair um I'm still
trying to get up the speed of the
difference between a service dog and a
comfort dog the Ada publication got
here um it says the service animals are
dog they only this dog but you mentioned
it might be a horse so I'm really
confused and then the other issue is
they service dogs have to uh help with a
disability and um it includes
psychological disability uh so if you
have an anxiety attack and you can show
that the dog helps you with the anxiety
attack it's a service dog so I'm really
confused the difference between a
comfort dog I think we have definition
problems it's going to be difficult to
create legislation in a system until we
get these definitions really defined
somehow any comments on these
definitions and how overlapping they
appear to be um well a comfort dog or or
animals is ordinarily you may be
prescribed by could be prescribed by a
physician to help calm somebody down but
in terms of the Ada and the federal law
there's service animals and then there's
non-service anim animals in terms of uh
these rights of access to public
accommodations so I mean I'm not a
lawyer but the the
um um you know all all the all the all
restaurants and hotels are not
obligated uh typically to take
non-service dogs they can set up their
own rules as they want but service
animals are um absolutely
you know granted the
accommodations and uh I think also
granted not just the service uh the
individual with a disability but also uh
the trainer of the animal uh would be gr
granted access along with the service
animal so but if if you if
um um so I guess that's about as much
depth as I can go into right now but uh
people a lot of times they show up and
first they're they're a comfort animal
and then they realize that that's not
going to get them into the into the
hotel so it becomes a service dog at
some point or service
animal that's where we have the problem
any other questions from the committee
represent Penza I know time sorry madam
chair all right just real quick um
because I think that this could possibly
be helpful because we're there's a lot
of conversation that has been brought up
about a lot of these things are going to
um really need to be handled on the
federal level um or there needs to be uh
further definitions and and um some
clarifications that are taking place
there um would it be helpful if our
committee came together and um you know
with a letter to our federal delegation
asking them to um to kind of step into
this issue maybe we can even uh speak to
our friends on the other side of the
aisle that are part of their um
environment uh agriculture committee and
um and and see if we could do a joint
letter that to our federal delegation in
regards with this um especially if this
is going to be something that turns into
a study committee just to bring some
attention to it because I it's been an
issue covid is really where I feel it
this kind of went um to the point okay
yeah exploded so um what Would You Do
you think that would be a good idea
helpful
just just for the federal government to
know that we're looking at at Poss
possibly suggesting reforms uh on this
and that um you know we're going to have
a coalition representing or a committee
representing kind of all sides so that
uh if there are suggestions that fully
protect the disabled and their their
rights and their accesses but uh uh
could impact the
um the misbranding and and uh abuse
really of of the law I it sounds like a
reasonable idea to me I just I just
would want
everybody uh that that really
understands the life of the disabled as
well as those who understand what it's
like to run a a business that uh
operates that way uh be included thank
you representative Bixby yeah um I'm was
just looking at the study committee
section of the bill as written uh and I
noticed that you have three members of
the Senate and a quorum of
four um have you ever seen three members
committee yeah that's probably more than
we need in the Senate so so if we change
that to one Senator and a quorum of
three you would be fine with it yeah
yeah thank
you yeah good catch all right any other
questions for representative Stringham
thank you so much for coming and
introducing this bill and enduring
lengthy
questions um we have two more pink cards
if anybody else has a pink card please
send it up to the to to me I will call
our Commissioner of Department of
Agriculture Sean
commissioner thank you madam chairman
members of the committee for the record
I am Sean
Jasper commissioner of the Department of
Agriculture markets and food uh I'm
going to bite my tongue on all my
personal feelings here but I will so
I'll just stick to the to the issue um
the Department of Agriculture is not the
place for the form to be created I would
would suggest and you will hear from
um uh Mr SE on from the governor's uh
Commission on disability I would suggest
and I'm not saying that he's he's agreed
but certainly they would be in a better
better position to create a form I have
looked at the law I don't think a a form
could be created such as this that would
meet the uh federal law and so if you
decided to send it to the Department of
Agriculture um unless the the Attorney
General's office signed off on it I
would have to decline to to create a
form that violated the Americans with
Disability Act that's just not something
that I would be willing to do but in no
case should a form like this be on us
because it really doesn't have anything
to do with agriculture even though we
regulate the pet trade still not not the
place where I believe it should be and I
will conclude with that okay thank you
any questions for the
commissioner okay thank you very much I
believe there's a pink card that needs
morning good morning my name is Karen
Rosenberg I'm the policy director for
the disability rights Center which is
New Hampshire's protection and advocacy
system for people with disabilities and
um I don't think we've I've ever been
before this committee but I've only been
policy director for about three and a
half years or so so well welcome thank
you um so I I understand that you did
secure some really robust research I
didn't realize that before I came but I
thought it might be handy for you to
have just a one pager with a highlight
on it which what I'm circulating or
what's being circulated is the Federal
Regulation the Ada regulation that's
pertinent to this bill that has to do
with service animals and the questions
can be that can be asked and the
prohibition against requiring any
documentation so um so to be clear our
office opposes this bill because we feel
that it clearly violates the Americans
with Disabilities Act and that it could
create potential liability for the
restaurants especially or other um
public accommodations that might attempt
to rely on this for form whether it's
done by the agriculture department or
the governor's Commission because um it
far exceeds what's what is um
permissible under federal law so um as
you know the Americans with Disabilities
Act was passed originally back in I
believe 1990 to ensure that people with
disabilities have equal access to
government programs employment and in
this what's relevant here public
accommodations and it requires um public
accommodations we'll just limit it to
that since that's what this is about to
make reasonable accommodations to their
or modifications to their policies or
practices to enable people with
disabilities to have equal access to use
and enjoy their
accommodations and the ability to have a
service animal if that's required is
such an
accommodation so what you will knowe
when you look at the regulation is that
there are only two permissible questions
that may be asked and and they does
actually does not permit a public
accommodation to ask a patron what is
your
disability um it a a per a um an
accommodation can ask whether um an
animal is required because of a
disability and what activity that um
what service that animal has been
trained to perform that's it um and it
also specifically provides that um a
public comination cannot require a
person with a disability to provide
documentation now this sounds all very
Broad and perhaps concerning given the
kinds of um issues that you've discussed
and that prompted um The Spill to be
filed um but there are some also some
guard rails in the Ada and there are
some existing Provisions in our state
law that address this so for someone
with a disability who uses a service
animal they are expected to maintain
control of that animal um if that animal
starts doing things that are
inappropriate like eating someone's food
defecating um the public accommodation
can ask that that person leave and and
and actually require them to leave um we
also have um remedies in our state law
for someone who unlawfully uses a
service animal so if someone were to
protect prend that their pet is an an is
a service animal and the um owner of the
public
accommodation um doesn't think this is a
legit service animal um they can well
they can ask the two questions but if
they're still not satisfied they could
contact the police it's a misdemeanor to
misrepresent your animal your pet as a
service animal so that's in 167
d8 which um probably your researcher I
should have made copies of that for you
all but I didn't um I'm I'm assuming
your researcher uncovered um RSA 167 d8
which um talks about what's prohibited
um which has to do with um it does have
to do with um if you go to um four
unlawful for any person to represent
that such person has a disability or is
a service um animal trainer um so and I
also believe it prohibits them for oh
yes and number two you can't represent
that an animal is a service animal um if
the animal's not a service animal and
then the next section of the law
um well actually the two sections later
167 d10 is the is where you will find
the provisions which make such um
activities misdemeanors under our
current law so I think that there it
sounds like there are some issues here
and that there are people who oh I'm
sorry sorry representative
wheeler were you no no no I was just
trying to get the just trying to get the
attention of the chair so that I could
ask a question when you were done I
didn't mean to interrupt you no continue
and and we'll have plenty of questions
we have plenty of questions just lost my
um so so I guess I've totally lost my
train of thought here but what I'll try
to I'll try to regroup um so I guess you
know I think what it comes down to is
that there may be more training required
for our owners of public accommodations
to understand what the Ada requires of
um you know in terms of what questions
they may ask what they can ask what it
requires in terms of the person with a
disability who is the Handler who has
you know and the control that's required
as as well as what the state law
provides around people who are not
entitled to have disab um service
animals and it also might require some
education of our local law enforcement
um in case they're not aware of the
penalty that's available if someone is
violating the law but but what we don't
want to do is punish people with
disabilities or make them feel unwelcome
require them to go through additional
Hoops um that people who don't
experience a disability would have to go
through so I'm happy to take any
questions thank you yeah we we
absolutely agree with that statement and
we don't want to um cause problems for
people with legitimate
disabilities so um
but given given what we've heard
already how how does a a a a an
establishment owner deal with that
situation given that they can't ask for
any kind of proof I
mean that that's just I mean they can
ask those two questions I had you know
even earlier today in an earlier hearing
somebody brought a dog into the
committee room which is not
allowed and the only question I can ask
is you know is that a service
animal I I don't know for sure if it's
it was or was not but that's all I can
ask well right you could ask whether um
it's required because they need to have
this animal because of a disability and
what service that animal um has been
trained to perform what task or work
that animal has been trained to perform
you could ask those two questions and it
is possible that someone could lie about
that right and I mean it would be great
if we lived in a society where everyone
was honest all the time and we didn't
you know and and we didn't actually need
police because everyone just compli with
the law but we don't and this is
probably one that people do violate and
it's possible that some people could get
away with it um I suppose if it's a
situation where someone's someone's
gaming it they're getting away with it
but the animal is staying right at their
feet not bothering anyone not doing
anything that person just got away with
something that they shouldn't have right
but probably there's not any harm done
but the thing is you know it's all well
and good that we have a notice that we
can say that you know it's illegal to
misrepresent but there's no way to ask
for proof to to see to to
see that that that they are
misrepresenting I think that the reason
is if I had to surmise when the Ada was
passed and when the requirements were
put into place around the Ada and when
you're looking at public accommodations
these are places that people like a
store you go in for five minutes you
know or it's a restaurant that you're
there for an hour or it's you know
you're getting a cup of coffee or you
know so these are I mean but it applies
to other you know facilities where you
might stay longer as well but um so the
idea was not was to not have barriers
for people with
disabilities um does that mean that
someone isn't going to try to take
advantage and I think that the guard
rails there are that there are certain
expectations for how the person with a
disability um is responsible for their
service animal and and how well behaved
that service animal has to be things
like that and it is possible that
someone could have a very well- behaved
animal and get away with it and there's
I mean there's other things that people
get away with in our society too
representative
wheeler thank you madam chair and I'm
sorry Karen for interrupting you I
shouldn't that's okay should have
remembered what I learned in school
don't raise your hand while someone's
talking but I have a question for you
and I appreciate your concerns and
absolutely I what Madame chair said is
100% right none of us want to be making
people who have disabilities go through
some kind of hoop that doesn't exist for
anyone else because that creates a bad
dichotomy that we don't want in our
society but what I'm wondering is would
the disability rights organization be
open
to would their opposition be removed
from this bill or maybe even support a
study committee on this issue given the
what businesses are coming before and
saying to representatives and others
about the chaos that they're facing even
if that study committee ends up being
the result of which we talk about
maybe training programs for these
businesses and police officers to better
know the Ada or something along those
lines but do you think it would be a
good idea to beyond the hour that we
have here today take a look at this
issue as a state in a study committee it
sounds like people have concerns I don't
see us objecting to a study committee
just please don't put me on
it un spread you thinly but it would
um I you know it sounds like there are
some concerns and there could and I
could see um you know you can't dictate
what a study committee is going to
conclude right um but if a study
committee thinks that it would be
appropriate to consider training on Ada
I I don't see the harm of having people
being more educated about the Ada right
um and and I don't so I I don't you know
if this if the study committee came out
with a recommendation that um you know
we charge everyone five dollars to bring
their service dog into a facility you
know of course we would object to that
um
but yeah have at it representative
Scully thank you madam chair and and
thank you for bringing this valuable
Insight do you have a copy of the
legislation uh I do uh the only question
I'm asking is you said you felt it
violated the Americans with disability
Acts
could you please if you can um tell me
which one of the specific questions that
are being asked do you consider to be a
violation of that act well first
requiring a form at all would violate
the a because that's documentation and
public accommodations are prohibited
from requiring
documentation right that would okay was
this may I follow up please sure thank
you because it seemed like the form had
had everything to do with the animal and
not the person
so I didn't know if that actually would
be a violation yeah requiring any kind
of documentation would would prohibit
the Ada because you can't require
documentation about the animal about and
and or and also it exceeds the questions
that you could ask so the name of the
service animal the name of the service
animal's owner um the state in which the
animals registered um the function is
performed you can ask this orally but it
it's you're not allowed to require
documentation so um I'm just looking to
see what then there's a notation of
information um in a place to sign like
forcing someone to sign a document to
enter a restaurant when no one else is
required to sign a document when they
enter a restaurant would also violate
just the
Ada thank you okay representative Penza
and then Bixby and then H Haskins uh
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question you're testimony was
great um in regards with the 167 d10 um
and where you mentioned the misdemeanors
there was I don't know um a little bit
of conversation in regards with you know
an education piece um and I think that's
clear this is no one would ever of
course want to one question someone that
um you know has a service animal or any
of those types of things or put um
anybody in that kind of situation in
this committee
um as we said earlier
um um agrees with that statement
but it's such an uncomfortable situation
for um everyone involved a business
owner uh so I mean to me whenever
there's these uncons you know
uncomfortable situations education to me
is key but even for like our law
enforcement um folks or whatever to kind
of understand that I
I just I think if people understood the
laws and that there was a misdemeanor
but how you would go about that is what
where to me is kind of like a gray area
and I'm not saying you're going to know
how somebody would go about saying okay
this animal came into my restaurant
create created a problem they didn't
want to leave like anything like those
types of situations and I just in
calling law enforcement in puts them in
a you know they don't want to be as if
the bad guy against you know the person
that has a dis it's just all of the
Optics stink like if you I'm asking you
multiple questions in here is is there a
question yes so like how would you go
about saying okay you know we want to
you know enforce 167 d10 like the like I
you know I don't I don't know that I
have all the answers but when you were
talking about how awkward it is for
public accommodations I was thinking
about how awkward it is for restaurants
or bars when someone is intoxicated yeah
and they have to ask them to leave right
or someone is having some other kind of
Crisis or they are just acting
incredibly rudely and there are times
when those owners those business owners
have to ask people to leave and it is
about training um and in a previous life
when I was really young I volunteered at
a dropin center where um they served
people who were homeless this was in
Boston people who were homeless people
who had um different kinds of
psychiatric issues and we got training
to deal with people we had some pretty
violent clients sometimes and um and
that training was really helpful when I
was you know with one other person and
had to kick out someone who was you know
basically threatening me and you know I
my younger self was able to learn how to
do it and got rid of you know got him to
leave in a calm way with a calm voice
and you know then he proceeded to throw
rocks at the building but at least but
after lock the door so I think that
there is training that can be done but
it's it's hard it's scary and it's and
it's difficult but it can be done
representative
Bixby yeah so um I'm a I'm a little bit
unclear about what you whether there are
actually any um requirements for what
makes a service animal and is there any
required training for service animals is
there anything that uh can you just say
this is a service animal and then it's a
service animal well it needs to be
trained to you need to have you need the
service animal or one would need it
because of the disability and it needs
to be trained to perform a task but
there's not like a requirement that Acme
Service Agency train a particular
service animal because the thing is
disability is really wide ranging
there's all different kinds of
disabilities and all different kinds of
needs that someone might have as a
result of a disability and all different
kinds of training that might be required
um because someone has a disability so
like for someone who is um is blind or
has low vision like the service animal
that they would require would need very
specific training for that purpose right
someone who needs a service animal
because they have a seizure disorder and
the service animal is detecting you know
whether they might be about to have a
seizure and is alerting them to that
would have very different training so so
there's so I think maybe that's why but
there isn't there there's nothing
prescribed specifically which I know is
kind of what you want but it's not
really there right so given that uh is
there any way to actually enforce uh 167
d8 or 16767 d10 well I
think I think the place where it would
be enforcable would be where the animal
is not under under the control of the
person and is acting inappropriately is
probably where as a practical matter a a
public accommodation would have the
greatest likelihood of success because
they could ask the two questions like
any other
situation human nature isn't always the
best nature people could misrepresent I
mean we'd hope that they wouldn't but if
they persisted in misrepresenting the
nature of the animal they brought into
the accommodation and that animal was
totally well behaved I think it would be
really difficult I I think it would be
unrealistic probably to expect that law
enforcement's going to do anything about
it I I I I you know I wish I had a
different answer for you representative
H Haskins and then representative King
we're running a time here thank you for
testifying today I'm intrigued by the
second question I was only aware that
you could ask someone if that is a
service dog but does the disability
rights Community are they comfortable
with asking somebody to describe the
nature of the task which leads to the
disability I I don't know whether I I
can't you know the the dis there's not
really like a disability rights
Community monolith right people have
different feelings about this but what I
can tell you is that the law permits it
okay whether they're comfortable or not
the law permits this question to be
asked followup Madam chair followup yeah
so if someone were to say there's a
whole panoply of
psychiatric um disabilities and so if
someone says because the the phrase
Comfort dog has come up today um if
someone says that uh the task is
to provide
Comfort because an anxiety disorder
might benefit
having a service dog so so this is a
really interesting question to untangle
first Comfort
animals um who are just kind of they're
just animals that aren't really trained
they just make you feel better are not
protected right so they so although um
under the Fair Housing Act someone who
is a a tenant or wants to move into a
condominium or something like that could
have a comfort animal as an
accommodation under the fair housing act
that is not um recognized under the Ada
so that would not that that a comfort
animal is just an animal that makes you
feel better right and and but if but if
you had anxiety you don't have to
disclose you have anxiety but if the
task of the um an I'm trying to you know
the animals is performing a task maybe
for the person who has anxiety who has a
service animal maybe the service that
that animal provides is reminding like
giving them a nudge they remember to
take their medication or it it may it
may have some other function that is
that they really needed training for but
they still are no under no obligation to
tell a public accommodation what their
disability is okay thank you
representative
King thank you madam chair um is it
legally allowed for an establishment to
refuse um all dogs for period you can't
they could refuse not you can't refuse
service animals there's there's no
establishment whatsoever what what if
it's like a swimming pool and the
service animal swims the person back and
forth across the lanes like I think that
um I mean do you have to allow a service
animal in the pool too so it can carry
the person back and forth I I just there
has to be limits somewhere there are
like well like a hotel for example could
have an area where um you know if people
have are allergic to animals that you
could have an area of the hotel like you
could you could have an area that would
allow someone because you could have
conflicting disabilities right or
conflicting situations where the animal
is not required as long as you basically
made the animal available everywhere
else um so I your question about the
pool um I I just don't know off the top
of my head I think I'd D on the side of
caution and let the you know unless
there's some reason for the animal not
to be there that would cause a f the the
other guard is fundamental alteration so
if if requiring um an accommodation
would be a fundamental alteration of the
public accommodation purpose or C cause
an undue burden then that would be a
limit um and I haven't really thought I
would really need to think through the
swimming pool issue okay thank you any
other questions from the committee
representative
Kenny yes thank you um I just wanted to
know
um if someone when it when someone gets
a dog that's supposed to be helping them
do would they then get upset that other
people were bringing dogs in that would
not be I mean I can't imagine being a
handicapped person and waiting for that
dog and loving that dog then someone
else walks in that doesn't have that
same connection and they're just playing
it why there isn't something that can be
done no I mean I I think that is an
issue that I've that some people with
disabilities feeli like you know that
you know when they're that there could
be people who you know don't need the
you know especially if their animals are
disruptive and they are doing something
you know that might disrupt their
service animal I'm sure I can understand
how that could be an issue but by the
same token this the Ada was enacted to
protect this group group of people and
we need to be and and you know and we
need to be careful that any legislation
doesn't conflict with that or you know
even though some people might get away
with something but they
shouldn't hey just a quick yes or no
question notice that says it is illegal
to misrepresent a pet as a service
animal with fines up to $1,200 would it
be out of bounds to um if you suspect
that an animal is does is not a service
animal to just point to the sign and say
say I'd like to remind you or are you
aware
um well I think it's I think that there
might be some risk you know we live in a
very litigious Society right so um and I
am a lawyer but um I think that you know
there might be some concern about about
that the limits yeah so I don't know
that might be a little bit risky but
I've seen businesses regularly um you
know like where I go grocery shopping
they have a sign right at the front door
and there's like a local restaurant I
like to go to that has it on their
website so there are a lot of ways that
businesses get the word out there um so
it might be you know depending how it
comes down if it's if it's a person
who's you know gaming it and they get
this notice then they probably don't
have if they you know they would be hard
pressed to bring a discrimination
complaint right but if if the um
accommodation um owner was wrong about
that then um yeah they might be opening
themselves up to some liability okay
thank you okay any other
questions we have one last person so I
don't know uh we would be cutting into
our lunchtime and I I hope that that
would be okay with everybody otherwise
we would have to recess let's go ahead
all right I'll call Chuck say
thank
[Laughter]
you thank you so much sure by all means
and good afternoon Madam chair and
members of this honorable committee uh
for the record my name is Chuck SE last
name spelling is s like Sam a i a and I
am the executive director of the
governance Commission on disability by
way of background governance Commission
on disability is an executive branch
state agency um right within the
organizational structure of the state
within the governor's office
um we are all about education and
resource uh and really the Integrity of
the Americans with Disabilities Act um
so I commend all of you for the
questions that you're asking today this
was a very robust discussion and these
are the questions that we see on a
regular basis uh that uh come into our
office as it relates to service animals
in the interest of time you know I I
think you all have a pretty good grasp
you you have ada.gov in your possession
you have the decal which is so that
decal goes back to about four years ago
maybe six years ago a couple of few
legislative sessions ago so that's
actually statutory where the legislature
decided that the governance Commission
on disability and Secretary of State's
office sh shall work together and
produce that decal that businesses can
now post um as it relates to the
misrepresentation um of service animals
so I I offer the services of the
governor's Commission on disability um
as you move forward with this um we're
very acclimated to the Ada I'm not
taking a position on this bill because
of our position in state government you
are all the policy makers however we we
do sit as a resource should this go into
work sessions should this go um into a
study
committee okay thank you
so given that you understand what the
issue
is do you see any remedy and anything
that could help our our uh business
owners and and again I want to reiterate
there's there we don't want to
interfere or cause hardship or burden to
people who have legitimate disabilities
yeah we are trying to address the
problem and it is a real problem of um
of people who are misusing abusing this
privilege and um and causing problems uh
so so I I since you are you know one of
the experts here what would be your
advice in terms of the the direction
that we should pursue yeah it it's a
it's a great question um and again I
applaud all of you because what I hear
you you are upholding the Integrity of
the Ada and and in the same breath you
are looking at what can we do because if
you are an individual with a disability
and you have a service animal and you
have the fake that's coming into the
same um establishment
there is a the individual with a
disability wants their rights upheld
because they're entitled to that um
legitimately again the discussions that
happened today it really does go back to
the Americans with Disabilities Act um
it's very it it tells us in so many
words uh if it's not obvious that it is
a service animal then you can ask the
two questions and that's federal law and
as you all know state law can't do
anything to hamper federal law so
therein lies it's I mean when you look
even myself how and I have to tell you
because you all have great questions and
the question regarding the support
animal emotional support or
companion there are many times when the
call comes into our office and there are
times when I am dealing with the citizen
um in conjunction with my staff there
two members of the staff here with me
today it's not an answer they want to
hear but because of the Ada it depends
it depends and and that is because when
we're going back to federal law that's
what we're driven by and there sometimes
isn't a cut and dry if the animal is
trained to perform a the dog because
you're right service animal equals dog
the doj federal has um opined that
miniature hes also F fit within that
category we never see that so the
one the peacock loud I'm sorry no that's
okay the peacock the boa constrictor we
we've seen it in the news and at the
airports that is not a service animal so
the service animal is a dog um that is
required because of the disability and
is individually trained so in that
instance with the Comfort animal if it
is it a comfort but if it's trained to
perform a task for the individual with a
disability now we are looking at service
animal um there are recent legislation I
think it was maybe last session or the
session before there was an addition
that if a um dog performs the task of
alerting an individual with diabetes
that they have to
maintain that's service anim that
service animal can be held by the um
individual with a disability because it
has to smell the breath that's typically
where where the the low blood sugar so
there in there in lies the issue um I
you know Karen had referenced if a dog
is not under the Handler's control
that's when the business can take the
action and I sincerely mean this I don't
mean this as a cliche I think the the
legislature and its infinite wisdom and
obviously as signed by the governor with
that decal that's that's what I think
we're all trying to do is is to limit
the misrepresentation and The Fakes that
are out there because that does hurt the
Ada and and it does cut right into
individuals with a disability that that
basically have full access um with their
dog um in a doesn't have to be doesn't
have to go to a training school um and I
think you've heard that typically
individuals who are blind will have the
guide dog and that is in that is trained
I mean I've heard don't quote me please
but they're into the five figures of 20
$30,000 uh for the training and it's an
exhaustive very intense training with
the owner in the dog um and there were a
few schools uh that that do that but
other than that because we have to look
because we're Guided by the Ada that's
what guides um the
questions okay uh representative Bixby
yeah I I think that um we've covered an
awful lot of territory and I think that
what we're coming down to is do we make
this a committee a study committee or uh
is is there any hope of coming up with
something in a study committee that uh
and
and or or basically are all the options
that are available already out there and
we would be spending a lot a bunch of
time not getting anywhere with the study
committee yeah it it's
a it's a very OnPoint question and
comment quite honestly um if we have to
revert back to the Ada I because even
this statute uh the propos excuse me the
proposed bill when I read it um it did
say consistent with federal law in in
the uh introductory
sentences that is how we're driven we're
we're we're driven by the federal law on
this
one so
essentially we don't there's not a lot
we can do at the state level and we
might not it might not make sense to to
spend time studying it I with all du
respect I can't give that opinion to you
okay yes and I apologize for that
represent Scully thank you madam cheer a
quick question I promise um in your
opinion is requesting a somebody
certified that their dog is a service
animal a violation of the
Ada my my understanding is when I review
um again ada.gov
um
certification vests
licenses are not re are not mandated by
the Ada so we we see the vest they're on
Amazon they're everywhere the vest means
nothing it doesn't mean it's a service
animal so the the vest any type of
certification National Registry we've
had these
discussions that that it doesn't exist
so you couldn't go into a database and
say hey is this a service animal it
doesn't exist I'm just really stumped by
the fact that we can do that with cars
and tags on the cars but we can't do
that with service animals and you know I
don't I don't know that's my my thing
represent Penza and you'd think that the
government would be all over this type
of level of control because they love to
control everything else so um I have a
real quick question and has to do with
the notice um is there um I know that
you the commission has been amazing
underneath uh the the governor um I know
a lot of the work that you guys have
done so is it h how's this whole process
work is it um you know our our
businesses getting regular information
from you guys yearly maybe when they're
paying their taxes renewing whatever
like I was just going to say you know
education is key and so I think that
this type of um of information is is
really great and can help business
owners and um and then my other question
is um in regards with I'm a business
owner I don't even want to get into that
you know welcome into my store whatever
it may be hey just wanted to make sure
like I'm not going to even ask them
they've got their dog or whatever just
wanted to you know make you familiar of
the notice do you think that that is um
you know a problem for a business owner
to to you know just say hey just wanted
you to be aware of the law that's it
like you know telling someone the U you
know here's the law I don't understand
how that could be against the
law so um you had two questions uh the
first question is um that notice um is
housed on the Secretary of State's
website um both as a a downloadable
where a business can download them or if
if I'm not mistaken business owners even
request hard copies from the secretary
state's office and I think it's in the
corporate Division I think I'm not sure
we also make it available uh there's
links on our website gcds governance
Commission on disability website to get
that um notice um we also at the
governance Commission on disability I
have very robust social media campaign
very very um very robust on fa Facebook
um we have posted that many times to do
the best we can to get that information
out when a business owner contacts the
gcd and speaks to the team we ensure
that they're aware um of that notice to
at least that they can post it to a
second question I'm not sure if and with
all du respect I I don't know if that
Karen had reference would that
potentially open up to litigation I I
think that's where you were going I I
honestly don't know but I understand
where the question is coming from I just
don't know okay okay any other questions
thank you very much I appreciate you
coming in and um and explaining some
things further and um we will probably
be talking to you or I don't know well
we look forward to it it's definitely an
active discussion as you can tell yes
all right I'm going to ask for the blue
sheet for uh HB 424 unless anybody else
wants to say
anything I think we're good okay thank
you uh yeah I'm going to uh the online
uh testimony we had seven people in
support seven people in opposition one
person
sheet we had one person in support and
against and with that I'm going to close
out the um hearing for HB 424 and we
will see you at 1:00 for another
hearing going to get myself a miniature
with I mean that would be the
absolute um solution is to get a tag for
the
dog
e
for
okay welcome back to environment and
afternoon and um we are supposed to be
hearing Bill 2 HB 262
I don't see representative bord us
anywhere
so
well uh we can wait five
okay to be coming up also so we're not
we haven't opened it yet haven't opened
yet and I um we did receive a
um or at least I received an who was it
sent to oh it was sent to me
representative Bixby representative ktoa
representative
bordes uh
from Diane
Richardson regarding a
draft of the
bill that she wanted something done with
amendment was that a couple weeks ago
yeah um there was supposed to be some
sort of
amendment
and I I don't know I haven't heard
the easiest job clerking I've ever
[Laughter]
you um just so everybody
knows I I have um scheduled for 9:30
Friday morning this Friday um meeting of
the animal protection
subcommittee and I'm I scheduled it for
9:30 to
11:30 um I know representative coma will
not be here so I'm going to chair that
um and the members of the subcommittee
as I mentioned before were ktoa Kenny
Freeman has Haskin siketus I'm not sure
how it may be just a three of us and I'm
in I'm I'm inviting the rest of the
committee to come if they want um
certainly be involved in the
conversation we want to discuss um not
only the the musling bill that we heard
this morning but also HB 616 so whatever
work we can get accomplished on those um
I will work on some kind of amendment
language for HB 616 to to kind of chew
on and we can go from there but if
anybody else is interested in joining us
that would be
great uh so other than that um and I
will be sending out information to
everybody who has not already received
it about the young Farmers breakfast um
on the 18th in the
morning so what I'm I'm planning
on no it's going to be in London Derry
uh the
the place where they're planning it is
sunny Crest
Farm F 59 high Range Road in London
Derry and that's a young farmer
is yep 59 high Range Road High Range
Road 59 high range yep and that's at
8:30 in the morning until
8:3 oh I'm sorry 8 8 to
10 London
Derry I encourage you all to come it's
good
food and lots of great camaraderie I
they're great kids
yeah
um and then I'm planning on uh 10:30 to
11: we H we will have a couple of well
three four bills maybe to exec out and
then we're done we're done with our
after today we're done with all our
hearings our bill hearings so
congratulations um and then I'm going to
reach out to um Tara sad to see if they
want to do they had asked me uh for a
time to do a presentation from council
state governments the a people and um so
I I'll try and see if we can't schedule
them to come at
11:00 so that'll be for Tuesday March 8
18th and then we won't see each other
until after we get Senate bills so we
breather well crossover is April 10th
okay so anytime after that I'm sure
we'll start getting some bills I don't I
don't haven't really looked at what the
Senate bills are or how many there are
but normally we get something like five
six seven something something around
there sometimes just one or two then
again given how used to be that we had
like a dozen house bills and now we're
up to like almost three dozen yeah yeah
we do have there is the advantage that
the Senate does kill a certain number
they
come yeah that's just to hope they don't
is high range
roond high
range yeah High Range
Road the
18th 8 o' AM excuse me wanted this to
you Michael oh yeah thank you yeah he
told me that you were gonna something
thank
you
okay so uh it is now uh 12: after I
don't see representative bordes but but
um I will have representative Bixby
introduce the bill for HB 262
dogs and I will gravel this in thank you
representative Bixby for being so kind
and courteous to introduce this bill
yours right uh for the record
representative Peter B
uh straford 133
do and uh I here to
introduce uh HB 262 FN relative to group
licenses for dogs and what this bill
seems to do is change the definition of
how many dogs can be held under a group
license and uh changes the fees uh for
group license
and
uh makes a provision for dogs in in
excess of a maximum for how the fees are
handled for
those and make some restrictions about
whether you can uh ex change change the
number of dogs you have before shortly
before
licensing
um
and uh there is
uh one issue that has that comes up with
group licensing is that uh once you get
over if you have one two or three dogs
you don't qualify for group licensing
but if you have or I I think you have to
have at least five under current law and
if you have four dogs then you're paying
more in licensing than you would if you
had 40 dogs so I think that's probably
the reason the bill was brought in I
don't know if the bill manages to do
anything effective about
that okay thank you so much for for that
um and before uh I I don't have any pink
cards up here for this
bill
so but before I call anybody up I do
want to alert uh the committee
to uh cour respondence that I received
an email from uh let's see uh Diane
Richardson from working class
K9 uh she sent the email to me Barbara
ktoa Kathy Kenny I believe the entire
committee uh and also cced Mike bordes
saying that the we would be hearing
testimony for this regarding group
licenses the bill is introduced is
completely unworkable in the words of
her town
clerk I'm I won't say that what the heck
is this um as introduced it is a
nightmare for both clerks and dog dog
owners however in cooperation with my
town clerk and the sponsor we reworked
the bill and sponsor rep bordes will be
introducing this
amendment uh it changes the whole bill
fee structure and eliminates section uh
Roman numeral 4A which should would
mandate puppies as be rabies vaccinated
and licensed before transfer and no one
is keeping litters till 12 weeks to do
so minimum legal rabies vaccine age is
12 weeks in New Hampshire older in many
other states as you may guess I fully
support the amendment as it will enable
towns to stop losing money on group
licenses currently group licenses are
$20 for five plus dogs regardless of how
many group licenses are definitely
necessary in order to incentivize those
with numbers of dogs to license and
rabies vaccinate their dogs affordably
I feel this amendment is a solid
compromise individual spay neuter
licenses are 650 each intact licenses
are 950 so the dollar savings are still
there for owners with six plus spayed
neutered or five plus intact dogs I have
not seen any amendment I don't I don't
know anything but I did want to alert
the committee about this correspondence
or remind you that um that we've
received it
that being
said um I have uh this is for the clerk
uh I only have one pink card from Mila
uh Mara
sorry
[Music]
F oh Fields I'm
sorry no no no my I can't read very
well
okay and you are from New Hampshire dogs
and you oppose this bill yes thank you
thank you um thankes welcome good
afternoon and yeah H us why you oppose
this bill so um New Hampshire dogs
opposes this bill because it it it
appears to be targeting a subset of the
population for increased taxes um in
specific dog
owners many people have five or more
dogs they love the their animals they
they take in shelter dogs that kinds of
thing um and to Target them to increase
the costs associated with keeping those
animals is is inappropriate it it should
be
um costed across the board for all
citizens within the state
um the original purpose for licensing
was to uh have
rabies watched by the town people to
make sure the dogs are vaccinated we
could eliminate the rabies issue etc etc
um and
the that
doesn't parts of this bill do not do
anything to serve that particular
purpose and in specific having licensed
puppies at six weeks of age uh does
nothing to further the rabies
vaccination because they can't be
vaccinated and then if they're going to
be released to a new home at the 8 weeks
of age it seems absolutely ridiculous to
have them licensed for a twoe period of
time and it frankly looks just like a
money grab you know it's it's not it's
not fair it's targeting breeders um and
and dogs necessarily opposes
that um it as far as costs are concerned
my my own town of Epsom we don't have an
animal control officer we're not paying
anybody any additional fees for anything
if a neighbor's dog gets Lo and that
happens a lot we have a community page
on Facebook and we reach out hey my dog
is missing the gate got opened can you
guys keep your eyes out two or three
posts later oh he's over here on Orchard
Road and um and Zippity Do they come
over they pick up the dog and bring them
home and our neighbors are fabulous when
it comes to that we we don't have an
animal control officer we don't really
have increased costs with regard to the
dog ownership in our town and I'm sure
that there are many towns within the
State of New Hampshire that have that as
well um it's what 88 cents for printer
to print out the license for a dog now I
don't know how
many households have more than 20 dogs
in New Hampshire that it's a lot of
animals but it could happen and I'm I'm
just not aware of them um but still it's
ink for the printer it's a minimal
amount for a tag um and and and as I
understand it there are many towns that
don't actually issue the individual tag
for the dogs they just give the group
license and walk on
so with that we are opposed to this bill
okay thank you um I I'd like to ask you
if you think the way the current statute
is written if you feel that there's any
problem with
it the fee structure or anything else I
don't necessarily see a problem with it
no okay um I mean if they were to if
they were to change the fee structure I
think we'd probably consider not
opposing that but again it there's not
really any increased cost to the town to
have the number of dogs okay thank you
any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for
coming to speak with us this afternoon
for listening is there anybody else who
wishes to speak on this bill and uh
representative King
Kelly okay anybody else wish to speak on
this
bill no um I I do also want to say I I
picked up um a testimony from Nancy
Holmes that was on the portal I'm just
trying to give us some more information
about this um from New Boston uh she
opposes HB
262 um there's a reason for the
existence of the group license and for
its relatively low fee much like the
lowcost rabies clinics run at the
expense of some of our local
veterinarians the group license is
designed to encourage owners of multip
dogs to vaccinate their dogs against
rabies this vaccination is a requirement
of dog Licensing in our state indeed
veterinarians must report administering
rabies vacines to the town where the
owner of the vaccinated dog resides ra
raising licensing rates and making tiers
of registration with increasing rates
are all actions apt to reduce rabies
vaccination compliance with some or
perhaps all of the dogs in a multi-dog
home the very simplest way to keep from
having to pay higher rates is to just
not vaccinate some or all of your
dogs the group license was never
intended to make money for the town's
general fund but to maximize
distribution of the rabies vaccine to
keep our citizens and our animals safer
from that deadly disease it is not an
overall Financial loss if its existence
keeps a rabies outbreak from occurring
please vote HB 262 itl as contrary to
the continuing effort to keep New
Hampshire Dogs R
free and so I just wanted to because I
thought that was an important uh you
know point to be made
um and that's pretty much all I have and
if anybody represent
Howard thank you madam chair I I like
the puzzle that they put in the middle
of how to uh the fees for the license of
more than seven dogs where you take the
dog you add up the dogs and you subtract
the this and that it just seems way too
complicated to me be helpful at all yeah
and and again I have no idea what this
um amendment was that uh was was
mentioned so I don't
know in L of that representive Bixby
your comments are welcome I think there
are a couple ways we can go with this
and it is the case that right now if you
have four dogs three or four dogs you
pay more in licensing than if you have
five or more dogs uh which I don't think
is entirely Fair uh on the other
hand it dog licenses across the board
are pretty inexpensive I mean you a dog
license now costs less than a basic
sandwich this is true for a year right
your license for a Year's license versus
one day sandwich one meal sandwich so um
so I I so part of me says it's probably
just not worth bothering with uh part of
me says well if we wanted to do
something maybe we could raise the group
dog license to be uh you know even or um
even with what you would pay if you had
four dogs so you know four dogs or more
you have you know there's a flat Fe for
whatever um but
uh given how many bills we have this
term I think I think maybe not bothering
with it is there there there is a fairly
standard procedure in many committees
where if the sponsor doesn't show up we
just it just gets
ited um and I was the unfortunate
recipient of that action when I was in
another hearing and forgot that I needed
to cross the hall and introduce the bill
so
um so yeah so well I'm I'm not not
strictly speaking but in this case I
think think that
um we don't have much to go on in terms
of and if if representative board us
were to come in before the end of the
day and said say I'm so sorry I'm I
failed to make the hearing uh here's my
testimony on what the what the uh
problem or ISS what the problem is and
and and how how an amended version of
this would fix it then I would say yeah
we should do that I that I wasn't given
that courtesy but that's okay I i' I'd
extend it to someone if they came in the
same day and said whoops here's here
here's an attempt to fix it I would do
the same but uh if we don't hear
anything from representative board Us by
the end of the day I think it's probably
an itl yep okay I'm cool with that um I
don't know that we would exec it out
today but certainly next week and we
won't know before the end of the day
sure
okay okay um I will then just say that
on the online portal we had one person
support the bill and three people
opposed the bill and I don't know what
uh we had on the blue sheet up there if
we want to you want to go grab that
thank
you it's well I think
the letteres kind of explained it in
that if you have a if you have a large
number of dogs like if you're if you're
breeding and you don't sell all the
puppies immediately or if you have say
if you're a musher and you have a bunch
of Huskies or
then having a large number of dogs to
keep crack of is you
know you may be end up changing your
tring go out with someone else you might
end up um you know people who have have
U hunting dogs will sometimes trade dogs
with other Hunters um so U maintaining a
so it's essentially it's a way of
encouraging people to make sure all
their dogs are uh have the rabies
vaccination and not give them the extra
the extra licensing fee burden or
and um I don't have any data on how
whether it really is more effective in
making sure everybody has every dog has
a babies vac
vaccination um I don't know whether
there's any sort of you know checking up
on that uh but uh I well I I know that
when you have when you get your dog
vaccinated that
of the vaccination report goes to the
city cour or or the town court right so
um so that would be you know so if you
have group license then you're going to
have like more than five five or
on okay uh I um for the blue sheet I
mean I already reported out the on the
online portal we had one person's
support three people opposed on the blue
sheet we had one person
support and one person
opposed and I'm going to close out the
hearing for HB
262 and we cannot begin our next hearing
until 2 o'clock so we've got a half hour
and in that time uh I just wanted to let
you know I had a um report done up by uh
our committee
researcher uh regarding animal testing
facilities in New Hampshire so if you
can take the time to look through it I'd
appreciate it before our next hearing
just to give you some background
familiarity um I asked the
questions are there any facilities in
New Hampshire that use animals in
testing such as businesses universities
or animal research centers specifically
biomedical research meaning the
investigation of the biological
processes and causes of disease or
research conducted to increase
fundamental scientific knowledge and to
EXP expand the understanding about how
processes in living organisms develop
and function if yes what kind of testing
do they do and for what purposes if yes
do any of them receive New Hampshire
State funding if yes what happens to the
animals once testing is completed if yes
are the animals harmed by the testing
employed the bill mentions traditional
animal test method which means a process
or procedure using animals to obtain
information on the characteristics of a
chemical or agent and that generates
information regarding the ability of a
chemical or agent to produce a specific
biological effect under specified
conditions do any of the testing methods
used employ these tests or other tests
and finally what other states pass
similar Le
legislation so um Christie tackled this
uh made a bunch of phone calls to a
bunch of different places and uh the
result is uh some information that she
gathered for us so please take the time
to look through it and uh we'll we'll be
suppose
no all right M yes does it matter at
this point if there's a um amend
22 I mean I I can go upstairs and ask
the legislative service 262 was it 252 2
I'm sorry 262 um you s you could if you
like sure thank you
hello of which
see I think I only made enough for the
committee members
so yeah um I'll see if I can get a
copy
[Music]
yeah okay um this is this is um
representative K's copy if You' like
that you can add
that
yeah
for
e
what
different
sh
out
yeah
e
uh I am going to open up the hearing for
hb401 which is relative to animal
testing funded by New Hampshire State
funds and with us today is
representative Diane Kelly to introduce
her Bill thank you for coming this
afternoon and Welcome to our committee
thank you for having me um so I am Diane
Kelly um representative from Hillsboro
32 and um I am here to introduce this
bill um hb401 relative to animal testing
funded by New Hampshire taxpayers um the
bill seeks to prohibit the use of New
Hampshire State funds for animal testing
this bill is a necessary step toward
aligning our state policies with the
values of granite Staters and advancing
modern Humane and effective scientific
practices animal testing is not only
cruel but also relatively ineffective
according to FDA data 95% of drugs that
pass animal tests fail in human trials
due to differences in
physiology um rendering these
experiments an unreliable predictor of
human outcomes meanwhile groundbreaking
Technologies such as organ on a chip um
and advanced simulators offer offer more
accurate and cost-effective and ethical
Alternatives these Innovations replicate
human biology far better than outdated
animal models ensuring safer and faster
drug development the Trump
Administration made significant strides
in addressing this issue during
President Trump's first term Federal
funding was cut for several cruel animal
experiments including nicotine addiction
studies on monkeys and toxoplasmosis
research on cats his Administration also
influenced the epa's decision to phase
out mamalian testing by 2035 and
mandated NIH um to explore alternatives
to Primate Research these actions have
saved countless animals while
encouraging the adoption of modern
research methods unfortunately under
subsequent administrations progress has
stalled making it imperative for States
like New Hampshire to lead where Federal
efforts have faltered the recent hearing
before the US House oversight committee
on February 6th highlighted the urgency
of this issue testimonies revealed
taxpayer funded experiments involving
horrific abuses such as the infamous now
Infamous beagle experiments exposed by
the white coat waste project these
included injecting puppies with toxic
drugs severing their vocal cords to
silence their cries and allowing
sandflies to eat them alive such
practices are not only barbaric but also
gross misuse of taxpayer dollars this is
not a partisan issue it's a moral one
polls consistently show that most
Americans Republicans Democrats and
independents alike oppose animal testing
here in New Hampshire our citizens share
this sentiment we pride ourselves on
fiscal responsibility and ethical
governance funding cruel and ineffective
experiments contracts contracts these
values when Superior Alternatives exist
prominent Republicans have spoken out
against these practices for example
former Congressman Matt Gates stated
that ending wasteful government spending
on cruel animal experence experiments is
both fiscally
irresponsible or fiscally responsible to
end them and it's also a moral
imperative Senator ran Paul has
championed legislation to modernize drug
testing protocols by eliminating
outdated animal mandates by passing
hb401 New Hampshire can take a stand
against cruelty and inefficiency while
fing innovation in science let us invest
in technologies that save lives both
human and animal and uphold our states
commitment to ethical leadership thank
you for your time thank you do you have
a copy of your testimony to did you hand
that out I
can okay thank you mine's all scribbled
up representative
King thank you madam chair thank you for
your bill and taking questions um I
think the reason that is given I've
talked to people that have been in this
kind of field before and the reason I've
been told that why we even test on
animals is because to do those types of
tests on humans would be
unethical uh and I think to myself well
if it's not ethical to do it on a human
why are we doing it on an animal um but
then the it kind of begs the question
well if we don't do it at all do we risk
not gaining new understanding of nature
to the point where we can help cure
people of you know disease and things
like that um my solution personally
would be that no you do test on humans
that are willing and capable of agreeing
to and then you probably pay them a lot
of money and I think ultimately what it
all comes down to is money is that these
corporations can do these tests on the
cheap whereas if they had to do it on
people they'd have to have their
theories down a lot better they'd have
to be much more careful about the test
they do and then they have to pay a lot
of money so I think that's what it all
comes down to is money um do you see
that if we were to get rid of animal
testing that there would be a mechanism
to still do the types of research that
they do in order to find the cures that
that we're trying to find um I I
actually like your suggestion but um
there are so many modern methodologies I
gave out a handout earlier that explains
some of them they're actually more
effective and more reliable and cheaper
and faster and and just better so that
no living beings need to be um abused in
any way so those methods would be I
think the best
alternative um so I I have a couple of
questions um number one I appreci really
appreciate the sentiment of this bill
because I don't think that animals
should be tortured in in uh you know
like what you had said as an example uh
you know with sand fleas uh eating them
alive while their you know vocal cords
are cut or whatever that that's truly
truly barbaric um but I I'm wondering
though do you know of any facilities in
New Hampshire that are receiving State
funding that are doing that kind of
testing it's actually really hard to
track them all and that's one of the
things the bill says I forgot to mention
um I sent out an email late this morning
um mentioning a couple of minor
housekeeping issues one of which is that
the term under definitions in the bill
the term biome biomedical testing was
left in and that was left in from a
previous Bill last year Senate bill so
that was removed um because this bill
only applies to product testing um and
taxpayer funds and then the other thing
is that the final um uh section there on
um reporting left out the word annual so
that um that final section covers um
your question um it would be um
should the bill pass it would be um
required that the um uh speaker and the
Senate President receive a report
annually telling about where animals
have been tested on when by whom how
much all of those details so um it's
just really hard to track right now and
that's one of the things that I would
like to see addressed and this is this
bill only addresses ingredient or
product testing in the state with
taxpayer
right now we had trouble finding
instances of that being the case but as
I said for one thing it's very hard to
track and for another thing I would like
it on record that that may not happen in
the future so so yeah so I'm just kind
of wondering again if this is you know a
bill where uh you know it's it's a it's
a solution looking for a problem where I
mean if I I don't I I still haven't
heard of any places in New Hampshire who
are doing ingredient or product testing
using animals oh it's happening a lot
it's just not happening with taxpayer
funds it's um you know you know where
it's happening without taxpayer
funds I don't I mean I don't have the
details in front of me but it's it's um
it happens all over with corporations
like you know like I don't know L'Oreal
or something like that um that um test
their products on animals and we're just
trying to make sure that they don't do
it with taxpayer funds we're not trying
to I I would love to ban all animal
testing but this bill does not do that
it's not Banning animal testing it's
just Banning animal testing with
taxpayer funds and I think we have to
make a distinction though between you
know what cosmetic what kinds of testing
biomedical testing we're doing because
certainly you know we have the uh New
Hampshire veterinary Diagnostic Clinic
uh that laboratory that is uh doing
constant um uh testing on different
tissue samples and uh you know trying to
determine disease and all that kind of
thing so um you know I I certainly don't
want if if we do anything with this bill
I certainly don't want to uh to impede
or ban any of that kind of work that's
that's really important work that they
do that's why we had that biomedical
research portion taken out it wasn't
intended to be in there and it was just
accidentally put in there so thank you
representative Bixby you had a question
yeah so um
so to clarify you know what this would
cover and wouldn't cover uh would it
would it cover any of the basic research
that's happening at UNH or at Dartmouth
Hitchcock or at Dartmouth or other um
university not not regarding biomedical
research just product testing okay so
product and ingredient testing okay and
uh so are
there
so uh followup sure followup yeah so if
a um if a company that was uh doing
product testing on animals got a
um got a a tax uh invest a uh Business
Development tax break from the state
would that be something that would be
covered by this bill actually that's a
very good question and I'm not sure of
the answer to that okay and uh and uh
you so you probably don't have a sense
of what the Bia would think about that I
don't I would assume it would be covered
under this bill but um people speaking
after me may be able to address that
okay thank you any other questions
representative
Penza thank you madam chair
[Music]
um you might not know this or not um I
would assume that most of the if there
is any I I would say not necessarily
animal um testing that's done but
research and all that kind of stuff
that's done in Durham and in Handover um
those would be all um pretty much being
paid for by federal grants I assume yeah
as far as I know but those aren't what's
addressed here because those are
biomedical not product exactly they
don't yeah I
mean Madam chair all of the work that we
know that um when we started as a
committee and went to um to the state to
the lab there and stuff is those are all
pretty much
grants most those things were Federal I
don't even think there was any state
involvement at all correct no but the
state does fund the lab with a portion
of uh I guess the dog licenses or
whatever they there is a portion of
funding that comes from the state to
keep the the lab running am I correct
representative Bixby that's correct okay
but I don't believe those are for
products yeah yeah there's not a product
related most of the testing that they're
doing is also if you know there's you
know sick bird sick something that you
know so they're looking to say okay what
what could be in New Hampshire right now
something like that they do
investigative work um none of this has
anything to do with testing currently
there are 12 other states who have
banned animal tested products from being
sold in their states
but um that's something we'd have to
address with another Billard thank you
uh representative Howard and then
representative BX thank you madam chair
so um given that there isn't really any
product testing especially with State
funds now do you anticipate an influx is
that the reason that you're writing this
bill or it's more that it's hard to
track it's hard to tell what's happening
where and because it's hard to track I
would just like to make sure it doesn't
happen or either now or in in the future
taxpayers shouldn't be funding this
anyway it's it's something that
Corporation should do sure um so do do
we I sorry for my ignorance but do we
have any such industry that we would
should be watching at this point I I
think all um products you know whether
it's Cosmetics or um anything you know
so often cleaning supplies are dropped
into rabbit eyes or whatever anything
like that um right but and but they're
uced in New Hampshire I'm not we just
don't know just don't know it's really
hard we've done a lot of research we
worked with um Physicians committee for
responsible medicine we worked with
white coat waste oh by the way um Dr
Barnard the head of um Physicians
committee for responsible medicine did
send out an email um which I haven't
seen yet it just I think it just
occurred um but um we worked with
several groups trying to find um answers
to those and it things just aren't um
representative Bixby and then
representative King so I believe the I'm
not entirely sure of the funding stream
but I believe that some of the funding
for the um New New Hampshire
agricultural research station does come
from uh either indirectly or directly
from State sources uh is agricultural
research something that you would that
this bill would cover I don't think so
it it's geared towards specific product
testing like Cosmetics or cleaning
supplies or something I don't know
exactly what the follow followup group
does so um do you know of any state
where there is State funds going towards
uh product testing for the private
sector I don't I should I don't thank
you sorry representative King thank you
madam chair I'd like to bring to the uh
committee the attention of the committee
um an interesting part we haven't yet
discussed at least in the questions I
don't think is the last part of it which
is the recordkeeping requirements um
that seems almost like more important
than the rest of it because you know
whether I if I understand it correctly
let me know if I do understand it
correctly that regardless of whether or
not they get any state mone's where
regardless of whether or not they're
doing product testing if they're doing
any animal testing whatsoever they need
to report that to the house of to the
speaker of the house and the president
of the Senate so that that way because
we've already had a few questions here
what kind of testing is done we don't
know it would be really nice for us to
know what kind of animal testing is
being done in this state uh because it's
hard to if there is a problem it's hard
to fight that problem if you don't
acknowledge or know where it is so to me
that almost seems like the best part of
the the bill right so do I have that
correct mhm okay okay thank
you represent Bixby um is there a
definition of a testing
facility I don't know if it was put in
here I don't think so because that would
make it difficult to do the reporting
right um I
don't before I got old I could see
without
glasses um yeah I don't think that's one
defined so yeah no testing facility so
others who come behind me may have um
further
details okay Representatives uh grber uh
thank you uh Madam chair and thank you
for taking my question um I'm trying to
catch up and understand it the the I
have a question on the the last uh
paragraph 359
V3 uh it says um beginning January 1st
every testing facility in the state
shall make a report available to the
speaker of the house and representatives
president of the Senate which includes
the number of species of animals used
types of numbers of tests used and the
purpose of the testing for all methods
it doesn't say uh of groups who use
State funds here does is this uh is your
intention to have this for any testing
facility or just those who receive state
funds my intention is for it as
representative King mentioned so that we
can find out what really is happening
where so this will be any any uh group
uh UNH or private or whatever it is or
federal M too that correct I just it
wasn't clarire makes certain thank you I
could I could certainly get that amended
um I I also not don't know if you
noticed the word annual is missing there
so I had that added into the amendment
okay thank
you okay any other questions from the
committee representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair just a a slight addition
for every testing facility that could be
student outcomes for you know SATs
testing could mean anything so to insert
animal back into that just for
clarifying purposes that would thank you
that could be
done
representative excuse me representative
Scully thank you Madame chair and um
thank you for coming before us now
regarding the issue of the recordkeeping
I was just wondering why you decided to
make the two entities to receive that
information of the speaker of the house
and the president of the Senate I
wouldn't normally think of them as being
the folks that would keep that kind of
record keeping as opposed to one of our
health departments I I I suspect that
that came originally from last year's
Senate bill but
[Music]
um I didn't request it it came from OS
that way which I think is because it was
in the Senate Bill last year all right
so if if there was an an agency or
Department we thought might be the best
department to to keep these types of
records and track them you would not be
uh we wouldn't object to us making that
change I would like to I would like to
see who what the agency would be because
um I would at least if it went to an
agency I would like
oversight and um the speaker and the
Senate President
may be um able to do o oversight rather
than Le being an agency with no
oversight all right thank
you okay any other questions
representative King yeah the question is
for you madam chair or somebody else who
might know um I think that was a really
good question uh representative Scully
just asked um I do remember vaguely
something like that happening with um
regarding uh uh transgender procedures
in uh New Hampshire hospitals that they
had to report that to the speaker of the
house so I don't think it's totally
unwarranted for that sort of a thing to
happen but I'm just curious if you know
of any other examples or or or in your
experience why that information OSS
might have had that sent to the speaker
of the house and the president of the
Senate I don't know they get a lot of
reports of all kinds of different things
so yeah um I I I think that the standard
reporting for uh studies that are
requested by the legislature is the
speaker and the president of the Senate
and some sometimes times other other
entities are listed as well but those
are the the standard ones for just about
any report sometimes they're sent to the
State Library too um and sometimes
they're sent to the governor's office it
depends I don't know so I mean we if you
know we plan to do any work on this bill
um you know certainly we can take a look
and see who who would
be
um uh interested parties or or uh re
that we believe should get that
information so yeah um represent Penza
yeah um thank you madam chair Just In
following up with that I I there's so
many committees studies things that
happen that um the members of the public
would um really love to have that
information and it's it's not like a
place that um is found so like after a
study committee and that's you know if
it's buried into the general court
website and given to the president of
the Senate and the and then the speaker
of the house it would be really great if
there was one repository for this type
of information if it's not directly
assigned with an agency that makes sense
um with what representative Scully said
um you know there's from DHHS to uh to
Dees all of those websites they have
lots of um robust amount of information
but gosh it would really be nice with
all of the work that the legislature
does with both sides of um of the aisle
here um to have a repository for that
kind of information it's a lot of work
that gets done many many hours and then
it any other
questions seeing none thank you for
introducing this bill to us appreciate
it and I would like to call up our New
thank you for joining us today at the
house environment and agriculture
committee we appreciate you visiting us
and and uh giving us your thoughts on
this particular piece of
legislation thank you please tell us
your name where you're from and then let
good afternoon committee chair and
representatives thank you for having me
my name is Jade Adams and I represent
the New Hampshire's kid Governor program
in New Hampshire
Civics I am the 2025 New Hampshire's kid
governor and I ran on a platform
to end animal
testing I'm here today to support House
Bill
401 animal testing has been happening
since as far back as 500 BC that's more
than
2,520 years ago and every year over 100
million animals are burned crippled
poisoned and abused in US labs they are
injected with toxins and diseases that
cause damage to their bodies and Minds
most of these experiments are painful
cause suffering and even death to the
animals
they they live in tiny empty cages all
alone lab life is horrible and
cruel 99% of animals used in labs are
exempt from the Animal Welfare act
protection laws what's worse is that
many of the animals are just killed
experiments and did you know that nine
out of 10 drug medicines that appear
safe and effective in animal studies
fail when given to humans this is
because these animals do not naturally
have the same diseases as we do I
believe all animals should be loved and
cared for and I want to help make a
positive difference in the lives of as
many animals as I can can House Bill 401
will help lead us in this
direction we are wasting time money and
lives in fact we are delaying Real
Results there are better Alternatives
that will produce better results for
humans and animals animal testing is
outdated and with today's technology
it's time to fast forward from 500 BC to
20 25 and end animal testing thank you
for your time and I ask you to vote OTP
for House Bill
401 thank you we appreciate you uh
telling us your thoughts on this bill
and representative King you have a
question for for Jade thank you madam
chair thank you Jade for your testimony
can you tell me where you did your
research
um it's not the Humane Society the
Humane
Society okay thank you anyone else have
a
question seeing none thank you so much
for joining us this afternoon we really
you
yeah all
say I uh appreciate appreciate the I'm
Kurt aronberg and I'm the state director
of the Humane Society of the United
States now known as Humane world for
animals
um and first thing wanted to do was just
address the fact that it's impossible to
know how much animal testing is
happening in the state of New Hampshire
due to many factors one is the
limitation of federal law the Animal
Welfare act the federal law that
requires research F facilities to
annually report their use of some
warm-blooded
animals specifically exclude the species
most commonly used in animal
testing how about that including mice
rats and fish estimates are that these
species represent as many as
95% of the animals used in
research for those species that are
recorded there is no requirement that
the facility report the purpose of their
use so it is unclear how many are used
in product
testing in another limitation to our
ability to fully assess current animal
an testing happening in New Hampshire
companies must only report animal use
under their headquarters location this
means that if a company has an animal
testing facility in New Hampshire but is
headquartered in another state those
animals reported would appear to be used
in another
state so that would be false
information in 2023 just two years ago
three research facilities headquartered
in New Hampshire reported using animals
covered by the
AWA the University of New Hampshire
Dartmouth College and the hidden Brook
Farm however given the limitations in
reporting requirements it is impossible
to know how many animals are actually
being used in the state and how many
facilities are doing the
testing and as has been talked about
hb401 does contain an important
reporting provision that would provide
clarity about the number of animals
being used in New Hampshire facilities
receiving public funds so I hope that is
helpful to the committee in trying to
untangle this web um so what this bill
does do is when conducting conducting
any ingredient or product testing in the
state no testing facility receiving
funding from the state of New Hampshire
shall use a a traditional animal test
method unless such method is of direct
benefit of
animals so that is in here
that uh Roman 3 direct benefit of
animals means research or testing that
is specifically designed to improve the
health well-being or medical treatment
of the species being used in the te in
testing so I think that would cover many
of the uh questions about the the labs
in the state that are used for
diagnosing animal diseases and things
um
um so traditional animal test method is
defined as a process or procedure using
animals to obtain information on the
characteristics of a chemical or agent
that generates information regarding the
ability of a chemical or agent to
produce a specific biological effect
under specific
conditions direct benefit to the animals
is defined as research in testing that
is specifically designed to improve the
health well-being or medical treatment
of the species being used in
testing so if a testing facility
violates this provision it shall
immediately lose its funding from the
state of New Hampshire and it also
contains a reporting provision as we
mentioned um now while we support this
bill um we would like to see a much more
comprehensive uh approach to this in the
state
um and I think that that there's
opportunity for us to do that but uh I
think this is a good
start
um I know there are other people waiting
to testify
it's been a long day here so I I'll I'll
stop here and take any questions
representative
Bixby so would uh research done at UNH
on dairy cattle for the purpose of uh
determining feeds uh uh uh feeding mixes
that would uh improve the production the
milk production of the cattle would that
be
considered uh would that be under uh
something that would be banned by this
bill or would that would that be
acceptable well it would seem to me it
benefits that animal than it benefits
that animal but the idea is that the
production I if it was I don't know the
answer to that but that that's
why you're the people who have to
clarify this
but that's your job
fortunately uh yeah
so represent Penza thank you madam chair
um quick question you might not know
this or not that could be um maybe I
could ask a question of someone else in
the audience if they know um
obviously we're going to say that we
have no idea of of people that are
necessarily doing this right now so
let's say it's it's you said it's mainly
common mice rats and what was the third
fish 95% is the okay so um if someone is
doing that right now in their facility
um you know whatever let's say they're
manufacturing type facility of some sort
of product or whatever um in New
Hampshire there's no doubt they have to
if they have animals and any of that
happening there's no way they would be
doing that in New Hampshire without
certain license
they would have to have that um with
havadis all of that so we should be able
information have you looked in you know
has anybody looked into that piece of it
that's how we find the information
wouldn't you believe because that's
licensing is key in stuff like that you
can't be testing on on rats and mice
without having certain Licensing in New
Hampshire okay I I you know I can't
really comment on that but I what I do
know is that the last time we had a bill
in this legislature that dealt with
animal testing was strong strong
objections from Dartmouth College and
and University of New Hampshire to and
they made sure that bill got amended it
didn't pass but it would have passed
with the Amendments that they so they
cooperated and and they're they're
certainly willing to uh I think tell us
what they're doing if asked and uh
work toward
um a world where we're we're we're not
testing on animals when there are better
Alternatives and we can find out the
information by uh other methods and that
is what this comes down to and that is
the kind of
legislation that Humane world for
animals and other organizations like us
are working toward and and this bill is
a small step in the right direction and
we will be coming and hopefully get your
support for more comprehensive
legislation soon that will make New
Hampshire a state that doesn't test on
animals
unnecessarily okay representative Scully
thank you madam chair um thank you for
being here and giving testimony did you
say that animal testing is occurring in
New Hampshire yes do you have the
information the reference and the
sources that you could provide to the
committee what I said and I can I can
look into it further I'm sorry this is
all I have today is all right well
demonstrated need is always a a
wonderful reason for passing a bill so
if you can find out and provide it to us
it would be very much appreciated thank
you okay okay representative King you
had a question thank you madam chair I I
don't know if I'm going to have an
opportunity to ask anybody who might
know better I don't expect you to
necessarily but I'm curious about how
much sway we would or how much force
this would have concerning um Federal
military bases CU I'm just thinking of
like Fort Dietrich in Maryland and if if
Maryland passed a bill similar to this
would the feds even even acknowledge it
you know since it's on a since a lot of
that testing is on a mil US military
base and I'm just wondering if our US
military
base they would they just totally ignore
our bill I don't know I just I feel like
especially considering a lot of the
egregious animal testing happens on
military bases I just think that they
would probably just ignore our bill
completely yeah I think if it's Federal
property it probably has different laws
applying to the stuff that goes on there
but it would I mean not not withstanding
that question it's still worth uh
passing legislation that b bans it
so that begs the question what what
defines unnecessarily I mean you may be
you may think something is unnecessary
but the the reason why people are
testing on something so the definition
I'm I'm going by is when there is a when
there is a proven method to to to find
the same information that does not test
okay representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair I thought the answer to that
question was going to be it's
unnecessary which is not the right
adjective if you're talking about animal
testing for that species that's going to
improve their lives it it would be
extrajudicial it you know we wouldn't
really call it unnecessary but um I
agree that unnecessary is a fuzzy kind
of word well that's my that's how I'm
that's my characterization I don't think
it's any in here anywhere
sure okay I may be using the wrong word
okay uh any other questions from the
committee regarding this bill no thank
you appreciate you coming and speaking
with us uh zephen
yes sure
no there you go okay now can everyone
hear me yep okay great uh dear members
of the committee my name is zephen I am
a law students speaking in strong
support of
hb401 this bill is a common sense
measure that ures New Hampshire
taxpayers are not forced to fund
outdated unethical and inefficient
product testing on Animals by
eliminating State funding for these
Practices New Hampshire can uphold
fiscal responsibility align its policies
with Federal advancements and encourage
the use of modern human relevant testing
meth
methods consumers today expect safe and
effective products but animal testing is
neither the best nor the most reliable
way to ensure product safety
traditional tests on rabbits mice and
other animals fail to account for human
biological differences often leading to
misleading results many products that
passed animal tests later cause harm to
humans While others that might be safe
are needlessly discarded due to
unreliable animal-based
data at the same time taxpayers are
funding these inefficient tests with
when Superior Alternatives already exist
modern testing methods including human
cell-based models mods computer
simulations and artificial intelligence
driven toxicity screenings provide more
efficient and accurate results without
the ethical concerns of animal
suffering investing in these
Alternatives not only benefits consumers
but also reduces wasteful spending on
methods that science has already
outgrown um additionally federal policy
makers have recognized the shortcomings
of animal testing and have acted
accordingly in 2022 Congress passed the
FDA modernization act 2.0 I believe that
that was a bipartisan measure taken by
Rand Paul and Corey Booker um so two um
Senators who couldn't disagree with each
other more about everything else but
agreed on this
issue um and what that did was it
eliminated the federal mandate for
animal testing and Drug development and
allowed companies to use more reliable
Alternatives additionally the EPA has
committed to phasing out chemical
toxicity testing on mammals by 2035 in
favor of modern non-animal
methods hb401 follows the same logic by
ensuring State resources are not wasted
on Obsolete animal testing practices for
Consumer products New Hampshire would
would be uh would not be making a
radical change it would simply be
aligning itself with the direction
federal agencies are already taking and
ensuring public funds are spent
wisely um beyond the financial
scientific arguments hb401 also
addresses a significant ethical ethical
concern State funds should not be used
to support unnecessary suffering of
animals when viable Alternatives exist
major companies across Industries
ranging from Cosmetics to household
products have already eliminated animal
testing in favor of more effective
Humane Alternatives consumers
overwhelmingly support this shift with
polling consistently showing that public
um that the public opposes taxpayer
funded animal testing for non-medical
purposes this bill does not prohibit any
or does not prohibit all research
involving animals it simply ensures that
state funds specifically are no longer
used to support an outdated and cruel
practice when better methods are
available so in conclusion
hb401 is a practical and necessary
reform that ends taxpayer waste on
ineffective and unnecessary product
testing on animals two aligns with New
Hampshire policy uh with the federal
government shift towards Modern Life um
modern testing methods and three
encourages the superior Humane
Alternatives that are more reliable for
product safety uh this bill does not
compromise consumer safety it actually
strengthens it by promoting better
faster and more ethical testing methods
I urge you to support hb401 with OTP and
ensure that New Hampshire moves forward
with uh responsible modern and Humane
product testing policies um I I just
wanted to do a quick postcript um I
think that the reporting requirement
here is
particularly uh important I I did a
foyer request um to the state uh trying
to figure out the questions that you all
are asking about like where does this
money go is there any funding any of
that um and the person who was
completing my foyer request seemed to
not really know what to give me either
so I think that what this reporting
requirement will do will actually make
it so that we know what's going on in
the state um we don't actually have a a
a reliable mechanism of that and so a
big hope for this bill is that that
mechanism is created uh so with that
I'll take any questions sure so Mr wood
thank you for coming and testifying
so how do we as legislators legislate
something that we don't know I mean if
if it if we don't know whether this is
happening or not what's why would we
legislate it thank you for the question
and it's an excellent question um so
there's two reasons why you should pass
this bill even if we don't have all of
the information one and most importantly
it helps us get access to this
information because once these um
entities start reporting we'll be able
to know what's happening and where um to
a greater degree than we currently do
and two assuming that not even a single
um there's not even a single instance of
this happening in the state which I um I
I don't think is likely um it's still um
a principle that the um that the
citizens are on board with so there's no
real downside in passing something like
this even if the Practical impact is
minimal but that being said I'm not
going to um I'm not going to concede
that the impact is minimal I think that
there is an impact there we just need to
find out what it is so you testified you
just said that um that you think it is
happening in New Hampshire yeah where do
you think this is happening and do you
have any facility in mind do you have an
idea of that there is uh some facility
receiving State funds that is doing
these horrific uh tests on animals yeah
um so I I don't specifically know
because like I said I did the foyer
request um and they came back uh with
kind of like an uncertain response of
like oh well there's there's these
things that they involve like tests on
animals but a lot of them seemed um
Medical in nature um and then a lot of
them it was just unclear um so like I
said there's not really a mechanism for
determining like who is actually doing
it um but I I would think that um it
would be the firms that we least expect
I mean um if anyone's following what's
happening on at the federal level we're
seeing that they're doing all kinds of
crazy spending um that we didn't even
think was possible until it came to
light
um and I'm I'm almost certain that
there's something like this here as
well okay any other questions seeing
none thank you very much for coming and
speaking with us this afternoon anybody
else I don't have any more pink
thank you so much I appreciate you doing
thank you uh so I'm Joan O'Brien and I'm
here representing the New Hampshire
animal rights league and we're in
support of
hb401 um because we support any
legislation that takes us one step
further to ending any type of animal
testing or or animal
research I will Echo what Kurt arenburg
said and our kid Governor Jade we really
need something more compreh prehensive
than this um like uh Senate Bill 97
which will Outlaw the the the testing of
state 12 other states have this it's
it's very popular with the public ask
anybody you know do you think we should
be testing mascara on bunnies and just
about everybody will say no that's
that's terrible so it would be an easy
thing to
pass what's harder to get people to
accept is the bi medical stuff because
it's it's sold is so important we need
to we're going to find a cure for cancer
if we don't test on animals we won't be
able to find that cure and a couple
people have touched on the fact that a
lot of that biomedical research is is
frivolous um like for example we've got
uh Federal rep mace her oversight
committee is looking into some of these
frivolous studies uh like the one where
they were testing um to see if if for
toxoplasmosis by feeding cats cat meat
um so they're finding all sorts of waste
and the universities that get these
funds they get them every year it's
really just a money grab so every year
you come up with some proposals that
sound good so you continue to get the
funding for your for your
studies and I just wanted to put that
out there because everybody is always
harping on the oh we have to exempt
biomedical research well just be be
aware that it's not all really going to
humans uh so it seem it seems to me that
what we've come down to the two places
that might be actually state funded and
doing testing not biomedical research
testing are the Diagnostic lab and the
animal science program at UNH um I don't
know if they are testing I thought the
lab was mostly forensics I could be
wrong with the study that um rep pix was
talking about with the cows to see if
different feed is more nutritious and
produces less carbon I know that they
just put a canula in the side of the cow
it's like a window and then they feed
them things and they they watch I don't
know if that qualifies as product
testing it's not that invasive but it's
somewhat invasive I would say it's
lastly why you know why should why
should animal testing and it's bad
science um great advances have been made
for example we can test skin irritation
rather than you know putting CTIC
chemicals onto rabbits with um we've got
we we can create skin from real human
tissue and we can test on that and it's
more reliable it's more predictive of
what would happen on a human being and
economical so in facilitating the
transition to Modern non-animal tests
New Hampshire can move things along by
not using taxpayer money to fund cruel
and outdated test methods thank you
thank you you had mentioned some sort of
Senate Bill do you have the what was
that Senate Bill what 97 it's is no
longer active oh
year okay any other questions from the
committee represent
Penza uh thank you madam chair this kind
of is a similar question that's been
asked before um you know the two
entities that you just mentioned isn't
is any of that money really from the
state isn't that all
federal um federal grants that are
pushing that through for the Diagnostic
lab corre thanks for the question
Diagnostic lab and animal science
they're they're getting they're getting
money from the state definitely I don't
know the state funds all the UN all the
university system to some
degree followup follow and then the the
um the example that you just gave of the
of the cows in regards with that is that
New
Hampshire yes it
is sure you can go you can go up and see
it I think at the Ericson Dairy Barn up
Program any other
questions thank you thank you seeing
seeing none any other people want to
speak or okay I'm out of pink
cards um and we have on the blue
sheet a support of 90 people and
opposition of five
yeah uh I have five people in favor of
uh this
bill HB 401 and I'm going to close out
the hearing for
hb401 want to thank everybody for coming
this afternoon
testifying and um I guess we are done
for today and we are done with all of
the bill hearings for this committee
yay uh we will be
back as a full committee on Tuesday
March
11 next week with a committee work
session beginning at 9:30 to discuss the
bills that we've heard
thank you everyone and have a great